[Musique]
m
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons car
chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 2 mars à la
veille d'un énième conseil de défense
sanitaire jean castex met en garde les
semaines qui arrivent vont être
difficiles
alors pour éviter un nouveau confinement
le gouvernement accélère sa campagne de
vaccination pharmaciens sages-femmes et
infirmiers s'y mettent aussi
astrazeneca désormais étendu aux plus de
65 ans avec comorbidités mais seuls 25%
des doses reçues de ce vaccin ont été
utilisés le parquet national financier
est-il politisé at il remporté une
victoire dans le cas de la sphère
sarkozy ces méthodes sont elles
contestable oui ou non le pnf a dans
toutes les têtes en tout cas au
lendemain de la condamnation par la
justice d'un nouveau col blanc l'ancien
président de la république depuis sa
création en 2013 par françois hollande
cette institution est souvent décrié
pour sa partialité particulièrement
contre la droite mais aussi ses méthodes
d'investigation poussive ce sera l'objet
de notre face à face
[Musique]
situation plus que jamais confuse en
arménie où le président on vient de
refuser une seconde fois de limoger le
chef d'état major
ce dernier poussé vers la sortie par le
premier ministre fabulizés d'avoir signé
cet automne un accord de paix avec
l'azerbaïdjan
la proposition de nikol pashinian
d'élections anticipées n'apaise toujours
pas la rue nous irons sur place à erevan
[Musique]
reporters sans frontières dépose une
plainte en allemagne pour crimes contre
l'humanité et porte sur la persécution
généralisée et systématique des
journalistes en arabie saoudite mais
vise notamment le prince héritier
d'arabie saoudite mohammad bin salman
ainsi que quatre autres hauts
responsables saoudiens
les ong dénoncent sa responsabilité dans
l'assassinât du journaliste jamal
nakache audi
[Musique]
sur le front du coronavirus veille d'un
conseil de défense sanitaire jean castex
met donc en garde les semaines qui vont
arriver vont être difficiles
une déclaration tempéré par gabriela
talent qui évoque une lumière au bout du
tunnel avec la vaccination
pour plus de précisions nous retrouvons
tout de suite en direct mona amoud et
laure direct de l'elysée bonsoir mona
alors on le sait le gouvernement veut
accélérer la campagne de vaccination la
haute autorité de la santé a évoqué de
nouvelles mesures pour aller plus vite
oui vous l'avez dit le gouvernement veut
passer à la vitesse supérieure alors si
seuls les médecins pouvaient est vacciné
la haute autorité de la santé recommande
que les pharmaciens les infirmer ou
encore les sages femmes puissent
vacciner à l'aide de tous les vaccins
confondus à savoir astrazeneca pfizer ou
encore modern a premièrement l'objectif
est d'étendre la charge de travail pour
aller au plus vite et vacciner un
maximum de deux français et puis aussi
diversifier le profil des vaccinateurs
de multiplier également les lieux de
vaccination pour elle la simplifier
selon à la haute autorité de la santé et
les pharmaciens pourraient même
prescrire des vaccins anti qu'ovide
voilà pour les premières les principales
recommandations alors mona le vaccin
sera saine et a été décrié depuis quelle
que soit lié à son efficacité notamment
finalement les autorités le conseil pour
les plus de 65 ans
oui jusque là c'était un peu le mal aimé
des accents antico vide si depuis et
début février les 65 75 ans n'avait pas
accès astrazeneca et bien c'est
simplement puisque les autorités
sanitaires n'avait pas assez de données
concernant son efficacité chez un public
âgé mais une étude écossaise a fait
inverser la tendance et puis a fait
pencher la balance en sa faveur surtout
puisque d'après cette étude le vaccin
astrazeneca aurait une efficacité
comparable aux vaccins files heures sur
un nombre élevé de patients âgés
le vaccin britannique est presque en
train d'inverser la tendance si je puis
dire c'est ce qu'a confirmé en tout cas
olivier ferrand écoutez le la haute
autorité de santé considère désormais
depuis aujourd'hui que tous les vaccins
dont nous disposons en france le
astrazeneca le finder et le modern à une
efficacité qualifié de remarquable elle
désormais le vaccin astrazeneca va être
étendu aux 65 75 ans atteint de
comorbidité soit 2 5 millions de
français non écoute à nouveau le
ministre de la santé
désormais les personnes âgées de 50 ans
et plus incluant les 65 75 ans qui
souffre de ce qu'on appelle des
comorbidités des fragilités pourront se
faire vacciner avec astrazeneca chez
leur médecin traitant dans l'hôpital qui
les suit ou dans quelques jours en
pharmacie je peux acté que désormais
toutes les personnes de 50 ans et plus
qui ont des fragilités peuvent se faire
vacciner avec le vaccin astrazeneca sans
limite d'âge
vous l'avez entendu et les autorités
françaises veulent convaincre les plus
réticents surtout parce que seuls 25%
des doses livrées par le laboratoire
britannique ont été utilisés dans
l'hexagone à l'hormone à la veille du
conseil sanitaires un énième accrochage
sanitaire faut-il dire à quoi faut-il
s'attendre que prépare cette fois ci le
gouvernement
et bien s'il n'y a pas d'amélioration
dans les 20 à départements placés sous
surveillance l'exécutif va donc devoir
décider en nouveau serrage de vis à la
veille du conseil de défense sanitaire
le gouvernement travaille sur plusieurs
mesures ciblées et très concrètes comme
un confinement à le week-end mais pour
l'instant rien n'était encore sur
plusieurs scénarios ne sont en
discussion et les décisions seront donc
prises en fonction des concertations et
surtout en fonction de l'évolution de
l'épidémie
merci mona hameau dès lors en direct de
l'elysée une politique de lutte contre
le coc vide en tout cas qui ne fait pas
l'unanimité parmi les détracteurs du
gouvernement nicolas dupont aignan le
candidat souverainiste à la
présidentielle de 2000 20 noeuds lancé
aujourd'hui une pétition pour demander
la démission du ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand qui bloque à ses yeux
des traitements qui soigne nicolas
dupont aignan président de debout la
france député de la 8e circonscription
de l'essonne est notre invité ce soir
bonsoir nicolas dupont aignan merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france alors votre pétition accessible
sur le site de votre parti debout la
france ô est intitulé pour qu'ils aident
pour qu'il arrête même de bloquer les
traitements qui soigne aveyron démission
on parle donc pas de vaccination quels
traitements sont bloquées selon vous
écoutez ce que je regrette depuis des
années des mois n'ont pas des années et
heureusement des mois c'est que à chaque
fois qu'il ya une initiative à
l'étranger intéressante ou en france le
ministère de la santé monsieur salomon
directeur général de la santé qui a
échoué sur les mac sur les tests sur les
vaccins et le ministre monsieur vers en
bloc les initiatives
je vais vous donner quelques exemples
très simple concret la vitamine d
l'académie de médecine on m'a dit il
faut absolument renforcer la vitamine d
des personnes âgées en france ils sont
sous 40 c e
il ya eu soixante treize professeurs de
médecine ya eu six sociétés savantes
rien n'a été fait e l'azithromycine un
antibiotique qu'utilise tous les
pneumologues eux
eh bien monsieur salomon a envoyé une
note déconseillant cet antibiotique et
puis l affaire l'hiver victimes
l'ivermectine c'est utilisé en slovaquie
s'est uni stylisés en israël il ya des
études en double aveugle c'est utilisé
en inde c'est utilisé dans le monde
entier ya des articles dans toutes les
presses du monde entier eh bien ce n'est
pas recommandée par mise de la santé je
pourrais citer enfin ce qui m'a le plus
révolté c'est con à l'institut pasteur
de lille
l'institut pasteur c'est pas moi c'est
l'institut pasteur de lille qui a trouvé
une molécule qui a des résultats qui a
été obligé d'aller quémander de l'argent
à lvmh et ils demandaient une
accélération des études et le ministre
de la santé le 9 février à bloquer ça
veut dire qu'à chaque fois qu'il est une
innovation
heureusement d'ailleurs que les médecins
prescrivent mais à chaque fois qu'il ya
une innovation pas cher réutilisant des
molécules eux
le ministre de la santé blog pourquoi
qu'est ce qu'il veut c'était ma question
suivante nicolas dupont aignan parce que
c'est vrai que vous avez cité des
traitements qui sont recommandés
lisez dans d'autres pays sans que ça
pose de problème d'ailleurs ni trop
l'hydroxyde qui n'était pas remis
également ses médicaments utilisés dans
plein de pays et des conseillers
notamment en france comment vous
expliquez ce deux poids deux mesures si
j'ose dire bien je m'interroge je mette
je pense que d'abord il ya le professeur
comme qui n'est pas suspect d'être un
opposant au gouvernement qui a toujours
été de je dirais dans le plus tôt dans
la pensée unique
le professeur comme lui même a dit
récemment on a eu tort de tout miser sur
la vaccination et on n'a pas misé sur
des traitements qui précocement qui pris
précocement dès les premiers symptômes
permettrait d'éviter le passage à
l'hôpital et en rhénanie réanimation ce
que je n'accepte plus dans notre pays
c'est que la médecine de ville soit
complètement court circuiter c'est que
quelques mandats 1 ne veulent que le
vaccin ou alors des médicaments très
coûteux
c'est à dire que les deux seuls
médicaments que le ministre vers en a
proposé et dont il a fait la promotion
ça a été d'abord le rem des civils avec
l'union européenne ensuite ils ont
bloqué parce que c'était totalement
inefficace et puis récemment les
anticorps monoclonaux qui eux sont très
chers et qui n'ont pas eu toutes les
toutes les études d'application face de
phase iii nécessaire donc c'est olivier
ferrand il a abordé la question avec ses
traitements dont vous faites allusion
les anticorps monoclonaux il aborder
cette question jeudi dernier certains
d'ailleurs sont contestées mais la
france les a autorisé ce n'est pas une
bonne chose pour vous écouter ce qui me
surprend c'est qu'on a des traitements
comme l'ivermectine comme l'hydro xique
lockheed mais il ya eu beaucoup de
polémiques sur l'hydroxyde rockin malgré
200 études favorables
enfin admettons l'hiver victimes un
traitement qui coûte rien qui n'a aucun
effet contre adé contradictoires et
contre indicateur qui est utilisé dans
des pays européens dans le monde entier
qui est bloqué et puis en même temps
digne à un traitement là le qui coûte
2000 euros le traitement qui est très
compliquée à mettre en oeuvre
alors là il est autorisé tout de suite
donc je me
demande si les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques n'ont pas pris en otage
le ministre de la santé oms pour bien
qu'on comprenne le poids de
l'administration de mauvaises décisions
par incompétence ou quoi le lobbying des
laboratoires par exemple je demande une
commission denquête en étendant je
demande le départ de monsieur vers ans
qui eux ne comprend pas que pour lutter
contre une épidémie comme une pandémie
il faut jouer avec plusieurs remèdes
moi je ne vais pas vous dire ce soit qui
est un remède miracle pas du tout je dis
simplement que des médecins il ya une
association laissons les prescrire des
médecins sur le terrain soigne des gens
avec des résultats et c'est
extraordinaire de voir et j'ai eu des
témoignages de partout en france de voir
des médecins qui arrive à bloquer la
charge virale avec des médicaments
simple pas cher
pourquoi le ministère de la santé blocs
t-il est ce l'effet de la bureaucratie
est ce l'effet de la jalousie est ce
l'effet eu de l'influencé pharmaceutique
je veux savoir mais regardez l'histoire
de l'institut pasteur de lille
c'est quand même extravagant ils ont
trouvé une molécule qui a des résultats
il demande des études accélérées
on leur refuse et quant à parlementaire
madame vos nerfs à l'assemblée nationale
ose poser une question dans l'hémicycle
vous pouvez retrouver la question une
question très sensée très sérieuse et le
ministre moque d'elle et d'ibs avec à
prendre de l'eau de javel des
commissions il ya eu des auditions même
on les a suivis en direct sur rt france
d audition devant l'assemblée nationale
notamment jérôme salon est ce que l vous
ont apporté tout même des débuts de
réponses qu'est ce qu'un son jus elles
sont utiles ces commissions justement
ces auditions
vous savez la majorité a d'abord dissous
la commission de l'assemblée nationale
et gap une commission denquête il faut
quand même que les français sachent que
toutes les décisions sanitaires sont
prises par un homme sol
emmanuel macron assister d'un conseil
sony de conseil de défense sans compte
rendu écrit donc sans transparence est
assisté d'un conseil scientifique
il n'y a pas de contrat et que le
parlement n'existe plus la transférer
tous les pouvoirs
état d'urgence ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que il n'ya plus de démocratie dans
notre pays sur la question c'est le
parlement est rayé de la carte
ils ont dissous la commission denquête
alors le disait si poutine ou si trump
avait fait ça e on aurait crié à la
dictature
donc c'est quand même extrêmement grave
et au même moment les médecins qui sont
sur le terrain qui ont des partages
d'expériences qui ont sauvé des vies
eux ne peuvent pas prescrire autant
qu'il le voudrait
et surtout il n'y a pas d'étude
approfondie sur les traitements
moi ce que je demande c'est qu'on mette
le paquet financier sur les études de
traitement qu'on compare les cas qu'on
fasse connaître ce qui se passe au
mexique en inde en slovaquie et en
israël
le professeur schwarz qui est un grand
spécialiste vient de dire l'ivermectine
marche il faut compléter les vaccins
parce que la vaccination de ces
dernières une dernière question
on a compris en tout cas votre message
sur les traitements l'exécutif a mise
désormais sur l'accélération de la
campagne de vaccination pour je cite
emmanuel macron tenir les quatre à six
semaines évoqué par le président qui
veut à tout prix on l'aura compris
éviter un confinement c'est une bonne
stratégie a tout de même vous êtes en
accord avec ça je suis en accord sur le
fait d'éviter absolument un confinement
mais faire croire aux français que le
tout médecin va tout régler et
mensongers et je pense que le vaccin
c'est un bénéfice risque quand il ya un
gros risque facteurs de comorbidité un
certain âge je comprends que des
personnes souhaitent se faire vacciner
quand les vaccins mais vouloir vacciner
toute la population est une hérésie
médical puisque l'aco vide ne présentent
aucun risque pour des gens qui nous pas
de facteurs de comorbidité et qu'ils
sont en bonne santé et qu'ils ont
l'immunité naturelle
d'ailleurs il ya 3 millions +3 millions
de français qui ont surmonté la commune
qui ont une immunité naturelle
alors pourquoi leur vendre un vaccin qui
leur est arrivé voilà c'est pareil avec
le vaccin puisque au pays à des vaccins
qui vont pas qui ne protège pas du
variant sud africain donc ce que je
voudrais c'est que on arrête les guerres
de religion il peut y avoir des vaccins
utile pour certaines personnes point
gros risques
il peut y avoir des traitements beaucoup
plus doux beaucoup plus efficace et puis
il faudra aussi augmenter les lits les
lits d'hospitalisation parce que nos
soignants n'en peuvent plus et il ya
d'autres maladies en france il ya des
maladies cardiaques des cancers qui ne
sont pas opérées donc je trouve qu'il ya
une espèce de psychose est
instrumentalisée par le pouvoir pour
faire taire les français pour les
vacciner et puis pendant ce temps là on
parle pas des problèmes du pays qui
existe aussi le chômage la misère eux
j'aimerais que l'on ressorte en liberté
et sa notation à vaincre le virus
merci nicolas dupont aignan d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france et au
lendemain de la houle au lendemain de la
condamnation de nicolas sarkozy dans
l'est fernique des écoutes par le
tribunal correctionnel de paris le
parquet national financiers au coeur
d'une enquête sur l'ancien président est
sur toutes les lèvres si la décision du
tribunal de paris ne suis pas totalement
les réquisitions du pmf cette
institution est loin de faire
l'unanimité créé en 2013 par françois
hollande après laffaire cahuzac
el nino rota mans pointé du doigt en
raison de son supposé manque
d'indépendance puisque les procureurs de
la république reste est nommé par
l'exécutif faire fillon affaire sarkozy
bismuth fr colère le pnf voit aussi ses
méthodes d'investigation très poussées
critiqué alors peut-on parler de
victoire désormais pour le parquet
national financiers dans la sphère but d
écoute le pnf et in politiser ces
méthodes sont elles contestable c'est
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
pour en débattre nous sommes avec un
jean de maillard ancien magistrat
spécialiste des affaires économiques et
financières
yves d'amécourt conseiller régional
nouvelle aquitaine ex les républicains
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être en
direct sur rtl france où jean de
maillard
vous êtes donc ancien magistrat donc
vous êtes bien passé pour passer parler
de ces sujets nicolas sarkozy qui est
devenu le premier président à être
condamné à de la prison ferme trois ans
en prison dont un ferme comment vous
qualifieriez cette peine écouté
l'apparence de la sévérité c'est certain
mais il faut pas non plus le citron p si
les juges aujourd'hui peuvent être le
sévère dans la symbolique des peines
c'est aussi parce qu'ils savent que ces
peines ne seront pas appliquées parce
que en dessous de 2 ans d'emprisonnement
les peines ne sont pas exécutées
monsieur cahuzac par exemple n'a fait
aucun jour de prison donc c'est une
sorte d'oxygène qui est donné aux
tribunaux de pouvoir prononcer des
peines purement symbolique qui vont
faire croire aux citoyens qu'il y à une
égalité des justiciables devant la
justice mais c'est pas tout à fait le
cas symbolique uniquement ça va
travailler aussi yves d'amécourt comment
réagit l'ancien soutien de nicolas
sarkozy et de françois fillon
non c'est pas symbolique comme ça c'est
verra comment le juge d'application des
peines va à commuer sa peine après ça
pour le président de république mais
c'est surtout une justice qu'on ne
comprend pas en fait je pense que dans
un pays dans une démocratie il faut que
les décisions qui sont prises soient
comprises aujourd'hui on comprend plus
grand chose dans les décisions qui sont
prises et cette décision de justice on
l'a on la comprend pas notamment dans
notre pays on avait un certain nombre de
principes par exemple le doute profite à
l'accusé et on a l'impression que dans
ce procès le dot a profité à
l'accusation
ensuite on avait un autre principe qui
était qu'il fallait des preuves
tangibles pour pouvoir accuser et là on
a l'impression que c'est plutôt moi
d'ailleurs dans les mots même que le
parquet national financier à utiliser
dans ses réquisitions il parle de idy
nous pensons nous croyons nous imaginons
voilà on est dans la présomption d'une
attention à agir face est très curieux
comme façon de juger les politiques
notamment évidemment à droite sont très
remontés par cette décision du chis on
propose d'écouter les réactions valérie
boyer sénatrice à l'est républicain des
bouches du rhône il y aura un avant et
un après cette affaire sarkozy que je
lis à la sphère fillon puisque je
rappelle que sans le pnf emmanuel macron
ne serait pas président de la république
puisque le débat présidentiel a été volé
aux français à la place on a eu le
procès de françois fillon
donc on voit bien que cette intervention
d'une sévérité inédite a perturbé la vie
politique française
cette affaire est susceptible de
remettre en cause les fondements de
l'état de droit
jean de maillard est ce que vous
comprenez tout de même la colère les
questionnements de valérie boyer
aujourd'hui c'est d'une certaine manière
toute la droite qui s'interroge c'est
vrai que le pnf condamne souvent les
personnes on va dire à droite
françois fillon en sait quelque chose
beaucoup moins à gauche en tout cas
c'est l'accusation qui revient très
régulièrement tout compris par certaines
personnes de gauche quel est votre avis
sur cette question
oui mais je comprends très bien mais je
crois que j'avais on dit le dicton qui
dit c'est pas parce qu'on invente une
fois qu'on est toujours un menteur
le le parquet national financiers dans
l'affairé fillon a manifestement été
instrumentalisée je crois que quiconque
est bonne foi est accusé de le
reconnaître
il ya eu une enquête éclair du parquet
national financiers une ouverture est
clair de dune information judiciaire ce
qui ne se fait jamais dans les affaires
économiques et financières
le parquet a saisi les juges
d'instruction il a choisi ses juges
d'instruction et le monsieur sarkozy
avait été be pardon monsieur fillon à
l'époque avait été mis en examen d'une
façon éclair dans des délais dans
lesquels la justice ne fonctionne jamais
donc de ce point de vue là je m'entends
très bien la critique qui est faite au
fonctionnement judiciaire
en revanche dans la sphère sarkozy je ne
crois pas que ce soit la même chose et
je pense donc qu'il faut pas tout
mélanger
monsieur sarkozy je ne me prononcerai
pas sur le fond du dossier mais on peut
dire comme le fait avec mon
interlocuteur que ont condamné sans
preuve mais je dirais on parle aussi
sans savoir et on parle sans preuve on
peut toujours accusé les juges
d'intention malveillante
d'arrière-pensées mais on ne démontre
pas non plus donc dans ce domaine là il
faut pas je crois qu'elle sait on peut
dire un petit peu n'importe quoi mais il
faut il faut essayer de rester sur des
choses concrètes
monsieur sarkozy a eu toutes les
possibilités d'exercer les droits de la
défense et aller jusqu'en cour de
cassation nili vin régulièrement il fera
appel
peut-être sera-t-il relaxé en appel
peut-être sera-t-il condamné il ira
encore en cour de cassation et je
reviens
même sur ce que je disais tout à l'heure
il n'y va jamais en prison en tout état
de cause parce que notre code de
procédure pénale n'est à la limite nous
permet pas de mettre monsieur sarkozy en
prison même s'il est condamné à deux ans
de prison ferme et la réalité des choix
autre réaction aujourd'hui qu'auront
chez celles de marine le pen propose de
l'écouter il y a beaucoup de choses qui
me gêne dans cette affaire la première
c'est que je considère que la
conversation entre un avocat et son
client est sacrée je pense qu'il en va
de la bonne administration de la justice
mais aussi de la démocratie cette
affaire est vicié dès le départ le
dossier a été pris en main par le
parquet national financier qui a été
créée par des politiques et notamment
madame taubira
il est devenu le parquet de l'opposition
je pense qu'il ya un problème
d'impartialité du bénef
on a la paix même devenu le parti de
l'opposition vous êtes d'accord avec cet
intitulé
ils veulent des micros oui c'est
d'ailleurs assez incroyable que dans le
juge nous reproche au président sarkozy
de ne pas avoir été le garant de
l'indépendance de la justice
alors que le parquet national financier
lui ai clairement aux ordres du pouvoir
d'ailleurs dans un article de 2016 jean
de maillard se plaignaient de cette
évolution de la justice avec un pouvoir
de plus en plus important du parquet qui
finalement enlevé au juge d'instruction
du pouvoir et entraîné la justice dans
un dans un scénario que l'on est en
train de vivre aujourd'hui en fait je
remercie monsieur n'avait aucune bonne
lecture c'est vrai je j'ai toujours été
personnellement hostile au parquet
national financier je le reste parce que
je pense que il
autre conjugue tous les défauts de notre
système de procédure pénale et notre
organisation judiciaire
mais ce sont je suis désolé de le dire
ce sont les politiques qui l'ont voulu
les juges veut et bien ils sont en ce
qui concerne les magistrats du parquet
sont directement aux ordres de la
chancellerie
on l'a vu d'ailleurs lorsque madame
blais qui était l'ancien procureur du
parquet national financier a été obligé
de reconnaître devant la représentation
nationale que l avait le subit de fortes
pressions et ces pressions d'exister ces
pressions peuvent exister mais en
l'occurrence ce n'est pas le parquet
national financier qui est concerné par
la sphère sarkozy l' affaire sarkozy
elle a été elle a suivi un cursus
judiciaire habituel et les monsieur
sarkozy lui toutes les possibilités de
le faire valoir sa défense et il aurait
encore tout la possibilité toutes les
possibilités de le chemin il va
d'amécourt nicolas sarkozy parce que
jean de maillard parlé d' une peine
symbolique il n'empêche pas nicolas
sarkozy se défend de vouloir agir en
quoique on n'est jamais à l'abri de rien
en politique ça aura de lourdes
conséquences
moi je pense que non n'est jamais mort
et d'ailleurs c'est alain juppé qui
avait je crois gagné le prix d'humour
politique en disant qu'il valait mieux
avoir
il disait on n'est jamais mort en
politique la preuve je suis toujours là
voilà
et on sait qu'il était passé lui aussi
par un certain nombre de situations
complexes notamment dans la sphère des
des emplois fictifs delà de la ville de
paris donc voilà la justice elle passe
et puis une fois qu'elle est passée
normalement on regagne son statut donc
il faut et puis et puis les gens jugent
par eux mêmes ce qui est bien est ce
qu'il est et ce qui est moins bien de de
la façon dont on est juge
g et de la justesse de la justice ce qui
est curieux dans cette affaire c'est que
les méthodes qui ont été utilisés sont
un petit peu curieuse d'ailleurs le juge
renaud van ruymbeke lui même comme il
l'avait fait d'ailleurs pour la faire
fillon sur la sphère sarkozy a dit qu'il
était un petit peu étonné de la façon
dont on avait lancé des filets pour
écouter des conversations recueillir des
informations
en fait la méthode qui est utilisée est
quand même très ressemble quand même
très fort au roman de george orwell et
donc je pense que chacun de nous si on
était écoutée en permanence sur nos
conversations téléphoniques
et si après ça on avait des petites
mains qui essayaient de mettre en
relation les conversations d1 avec les
conversations des autres de monter
d'échafauder des plans sur la comète
d'essayer de trouver des complots c'est
un peu c'est un peu comme si le parquet
national financier s'était amusé à
construire des thèses complotistes sur
les relations de nicolas sarkozy du
magistrat ibères et de l'avocat herzog
merci en tout cas à tous les deux vivent
d'amico en jean de maillard d'avoir
accepté ce fait à sa façon directe ur
rtl france merci à vous restez avec nous
dans quelques instants nous ferons un
point sur la situation en arménie
nouvelle mobilisation est vu à erevan
les manifestants réclament la démission
du premier ministre nicole peu chignon
et puis nous parlerons des sept finales
du jour n'est saoudien jamal khashoggi
rsf annonce avoir déposé une plainte en
allemagne contre le prince héritier mb/s
pour crimes contre l'humanité
[Musique]
jordan barre de la et marion maréchal-le
pen qui dénonce cette censure pour eux
facebook menaçant fait de publier des
pages de soutien mouvement génération
identitaire il faut en finir avec cette
dérive dégâts femmes il faut rappeler la
primauté du droit français sur le
territoire national des pouvoirs publics
en france et dans d'autres pays sont un
peu tétanisé face aux géants du
numérique
moi j'ai eu l'occasion il ya quelques il
ya deux ans au parlement européen d'
interpeller
mark zuckerberg le pdg de facebook sur
cette question il avait d'ailleurs
répondu de manière très alambiquée mais
je crois que ça nécessite maintenant que
les pouvoirs publics se saisissent du
sujet ils défendent la liberté
d'expression et s'ils ne le font pas et
bien ils seront complices
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci nous rejoindre 20h30 en direct sur
rt france mais manifestations se
poursuivent donc en arménie un pays
toujours plongé dans une crise politique
majeure
le président refuse encore le limogeage
du chef d'état-major un officiel de haut
rang ont poussé vers la sortie par le
premier ministre ni talent pashinian de
plus en plus en difficulté depuis
signature cet automne d'un accord de
cessez le feu avec l'azerbaïdjan dans le
conflit du haut karabagh sa proposition
d'élections anticipées ne calme toujours
par la rue plus de précisions à erevan
avec un autre envoyé spécial david
khalifa une mobilisation moins
importante que lors des précédents jours
mais une poignée de manifestants
toujours là pour réclamer le départ de
nikol pashinian et comme vous pouvez le
voir derrière moi des rubans orange ont
été accrochées aux grilles du parlement
un pied de nez fait à nikol pashinian
puisque elle représente le souvenir des
villageois qui sont désormais sous
l'égide de l'azerbaïdjan le premier
ministre arménien considéré comme
responsable de la défaite militaire dans
l'euro à karabagh et cette mobilisation
elle s'est faite en présence d'une des
figures de l'opposition vazguen
manoukian anciens premiers ministres de
l'arménie et qui a demandé à tous les
partisans antipas chilienne de
poursuivre le combat jusqu'à son
éviction
il a également précisé qu'un rendez vous
était pris avec le président arménien
demain matin afin qu'ils fassent tout ce
qui est sans son pouvoir pour la garder
en poste le chef d'état major de l'armée
vous le savez nikol pashinian n'a
réclamé sa révocation à plusieurs
reprises une révocation pour refuser par
le président arménien mais a selon la
constitution il est obligé d'accepter
cette motion d'où ce rendez-vous a pris
par l'opposition demain matin avec le
président arménien je vous propose
d'écouter base gagne manoukian à notre
micro
ni escale technique en amont aux autres
il y a quelques jours le président a
renvoyé la proposition de nikol
pashinian l'argument est temps qu'elle
n'était pas conforme à la constitution
la constitution n'a pas changé pendant
ces quelques jours donc ce qui était
anticonstitutionnelle il y a quelques
jours l'est encore aujourd'hui
logique il devrait donc renvoyé ce
papier à la cour constitutionnelle
c'est la décision la plus naturelle mais
il a du temps jusqu'à 18 heures demain
nous espérons que nous serons le
convaincre ou plutôt en lui indiqueront
qu'en toute logique cette proposition de
nikol pashinian devrait être renvoyée à
la cour constitutionnelle
ensuite la cour constitutionnelle
l'équipe du rap ans dont dix jours une
nouvelle mobilisation est prévue demain
à 16h heure locale devant le parlement
arménien afin de maintenir cette
pression sur le premier ministre
arménien à l'appel de vazgen à manucho
et qui demande à tous les partisans de
poursuivre le combat jusqu'à son
éviction à savoir que la sécurité a été
renforcée à tout autour des bâtiments
administratifs pour éviter toute
incursion à des partisans antipas cydia
mais comme il ya pu y avoir lors des
précédents jours on va pas refaire sans
frontières annonce aujourd'hui le dépôt
d'une plainte en allemagne pour crimes
contre l'humanité visant mohamed ben
salman une information qui survient
quelques jours seulement après la
publication d'un rapport de la cia
incriminant le prince héritier saoudien
dans l'assassinât du journaliste jamal
khashoggi ryad aimant et dénonce les
accusations mensongères
françois xavier lambert
la justice allemande va se pencher sur
une affaire qui embarrasse le pouvoir
saoudien dans une plainte de plusieurs
centaines de pages adressée au procureur
général de la cour constitutionnelle
fédérale de karlsruhe et reporters sans
frontières accuse plusieurs hauts
responsables saoudiens de persécuter
systématiquement les journalistes cette
juridiction jouit notamment d'une
compétence universelle qui lui permet de
juger certains crimes commis à
l'étranger et elle va donc devoir se
prononcer sur une plainte qui met
directement en cause le tout-puissant
prince héritier mohammed bin salman
il est accusé entre autres de torture de
violence ou de disparitions forcées
exercée contre 34 journalistes
nous demandons une analyse de la
situation en vue d'ouvrir de manière
officielle une enquête du ministère
public qui serait une première mondiale
avant d'émettre ensuite des mandats
d'arrêt cette nouvelle accusation contre
eux mbs s'ajoutent aux conclusions de
l'enquêté des services secrets
américains sur son rôle présumé dans
l'assassinât du journaliste jamal
arrache au gui pour washington c'est
bien lui qui a donné le feu vert à
l'opération
le prince héritier d'arabie saoudite
mohamed ben salman à valider une
opération à istanbul en turquie pour
capturer ou tuer le journaliste saoudien
jamal rachid
après avoir nié son assassinat ryad a
reconnu que plusieurs agents saoudiens
avaient tué jamal arrache audi en
octobre 2018 dans le consulat d'arabie
saoudite à istanbul
le journaliste critique envers le
pouvoir saoudien s'était exilé aux états
unis avant de collaborer avec le
washington post
selon le renseignement américain une
vingtaine de personnes dont l'ancien
directeur adjoint des renseignements
généraux saoudiens sont impliqués dans
cette opération
les etats unis ont annoncé des sanctions
financières contre plusieurs
responsables saoudiens 76 personnes sont
désormais interdites de séjour aux états
unis le prince héritier lui n'est pas
concerné par ces mesures restrictives le
royaume wahhabite continue de rejeter
les accusations contre eux mb s
nous n'avons pas besoin d'être soulagé
parce que nous n'avons jamais pensé que
c'était une possibilité sérieuse
le prince héritier n'est pas impliqué
dans ce processus et a été innocenté de
tout acte répréhensible
endosser la responsabilité morale en
tant que dirigeant courageux et cela
signifie veiller à ce que la situation
soit rectifiée et les responsables de ce
crime odieux traduits en justice la
justice saoudienne a condamné huit des
accusés à des peines de prison mais
aucun responsable de premier plan
c'est dans ce contexte que le président
américain s'est entretenu la semaine
dernière au téléphone avec le roi salman
le souverain qui a insisté pour
maintenir un partenariat solide avec les
états unis selon le classement mondial
de la liberté de la presse établi par
rsf
l'arabie saoudite occupe le 170e rang
sur 180 pays et pour en parler nous
sommes avec pierre conesa ancien haut
fonctionnaire spécialiste des questions
stratégiques internationales bonsoir
père connais ça merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france donc cette
plainte
on en parlait ce qu'il ya vraiment une
réelle volonté de sanction à l'encontre
d'un bs ou bien est ce tout simplement
symbolique
écoutez d'abord il ya un règlement de
comptes interne américains c'est à dire
qu'effectivement l'une des premières
décisions de ben laden c'est de montrer
que la différence d'autres enfin lui est
capable de présenter au peuple américain
la réalité la vérité donc ça c'est un
point très important puisque ce avec
trump et état d'être assez loin dans
l'ignominie donc il ya cette dimension
là qui est à mon avis la plus importante
pour ce qui concerne la relation avec
l'arabie saoudite le pays cette fois je
pense pas qu'il va être la relation va
être très profondément déstabilisé le
premier acte café by donne c'est de
s'adresser directement au roi puisque
vous savez que moi m m salman n'est que
le prince héritier et donc de s'adresser
aux pères de mbs pour lui dire écoute et
votre kamana il faudrait peut-être un
voyant colonies de vacances et le faire
disparaître pendant quelque temps mais
je ne crois pas que ça va déstabiliser
fondamentalement la relation avec
l'arabie saoudite alors en tout cas un
rapport des services de renseignement
américains déclassifiés 1 par
l'administration bei den 1 montrent que
l'assassinât du journaliste n'a pu se
faire sans l'aval
2 mb/s c'est donc très grave
effectivement ça vous semble cohérent
abbas est complètement cohérent
ce sont les plus proches conseillers
tuant probablement assassiné et découpé
en morceaux jamal khashoggi et le plus
extraordinaire c'est que ces gens étant
identifié grâce au service turc puisque
vous savez que les turcs avaient
complètement sonorisé le consulat
saoudien istanbul
donc ils savent parfaitement qui a fait
quoi ils ont donc fourni cette liste et
en dépit de ce que raconte effectivement
l'arabie saoudite 10 ans un certain
nombre des conseillers ont été condamnés
qui est intéressant c'est ce qu'ils ont
été amnistiés par mois mettre notre
salvador qu'ils étaient dans le commando
al qahtani qu'elles sont conseillés son
âme damnée
le général askari quel chef des
renseignements selon tt amnistie et ça
veut dire que probablement le régime a
peur qu'ils parlent alors vous vous
disiez tout à l'heure que vous doutiez
finalement que ça change profondément la
relation entre les états unis et
l'arabie saoudite que l'animation baden
préféré dialoguer avec le roi il
n'empêche le président américain a
également décidé d'arrêter de soutenir
militairement le royaume c'est tout de
même une décision important pourquoi ce
changement de stratégie
écoutez il faut vous distinguer le
candidat américain en campagne le
candidat américain où reposent de
responsabilité rappelez-vous que traille
fait sa campagne électorale en dénonçant
l'argent saoudien dans la foule maison
blanche son premier voyage officiel se
fait en arabie saoudite pour by donne
quand il est candidat et dis-moi
j'arrêterai les ventes d'armes à
l'arabie saoudite mais enfin je ne crois
pas une minute que si vous voulez il va
arrêter de vendre des armes en arabie
saoudite non le point sensible c'est la
guerre au yémen qu'est ce que vous savez
que les américains fournissent les
données de ciblage pour que les avions
saoudiens bombarde c'est que c'est une
campagne aérienne essentiellement du
côté de l'arabie saoudite et donc c'est
s'ils arrêtent de fournir les données de
ciblage étant donnée la maladresse quand
les saoudiens ont fait preuve jusqu'à
maintenant je sais pas si ça va servir à
grand chose puisque ils ont tiré sur une
école sur un hôpital de msf et des
choses comme ça donc tout dépend de ce
que contient cette affirmation 10 ans
qui va arrêter de
la bourre avec l'arabie saoudite moi je
perçois moi je n'y pense pas je ne
comprends pas qu'il n'écarterait à
mohammed bin salman
n'oubliez pas que l'on m'a quand même
pas mal d'ennemis à l'intérieur il a
pris tous ses petits camarades à l'hôtel
ritz il les a plus mais d'un milliard de
dollars chacun donc il a fumé derrière
lui il a laissé derrière lui des gens
qui sont très mécontents et qui sont des
princes la famille royale donc est ce
que le fait de l'écarter du pouvoir va
probablement pour beaucoup de plaisir on
dans l'entourage de la dynastie
saoudienne ya quand même timide presse
sur ce contexte de guerre au yémen que
vous venez de nous décrire quel doit
être le rôle de laura aux parents c'est
qu' il n'y a guère que l'allemagne et
l'italie qui ont arrêté de vendre des
armes à la radiation là vous pouvez
question oui sur concernant ce que vous
dire sur le gros se passe ici la liaison
est toujours bonne avec pierre connaît
ça vous entendez sur le contexte que
vous venez de nous décrire de la guerre
au yémen il ya l'allemagne et l'italie
qui ont été de vendre des armes à
l'arabie saoudite qu'elle doit être
aujourd'hui selon vous la position de de
la france beaucoup de voix s'élèvent
pour justement demandé le contrôle des
armes de la part du parlement pour
justement sais c'est qu'on vend des
armes à l'arabie saoudite
oui bah écoutez c'est très bien
qu'effectivement il ya en france
quelques voix qui s'élèvent pour dire
encore une fois que on peut arrêter de
fournir les armes qui servent à la
guerre oui mais bon cela dit vous savez
que tout ça est une affaire de symbole
des hypocrites parce qu'on leur vend des
camions césar ou savez des canons caesar
son des canons à longue portée
guidés par gps etc si vous les laissez
du côté de saoudiennes de la frontière
vous pouvez expliquer que c'est des
armes défensives
même si vous tirez sur le yémen vous
savez il ya une espèce de deux manières
de 2 comment dire de jouer d'hypocrisie
pour continuer à fournir
même en situation de conflit en phase
iib la france ça donnera une leçon
probablement importante encore une fois
un pays qui jusqu'à maintenant n'a
jamais reçu n'oubliez pas qu'après le
11-septembre george bush accuse l'iran
l'irak et la corée du nord ait pas leurs
habits cela peut-il donc il était
tellement habitués à ce qu'on les
tiendront les préserve qu'on les protège
mais si effectivement pour cette fois il
y ait un rapport
l'union européenne qui pèse parfois que
mon pourrait s'en féliciter il ya vous
avez en votre place
un responsable de lg à un benoît murs à
ciel qui nous expliquait que peu de
médias français faisaient état de cette
guerre au yémen et les armes la question
des armes à qui on les vend des pourquoi
comment vous vous l'expliquez comment
cette absence de ce sujet dans la presse
française
ben c'est plutôt avoue qu'il faudrait
poser la question moi ce que je le
connais c'est le côté exportations
d'armement se donner leur avis
oui je comprend l'arabie saoudite est le
premier client de la france si vous
voulez en moyenne lissée sur les trente
dernières années c'est à dire c'est le
pays auquel en a vendu le plus si on
ramène si vous les feuilles moyen de
trentenaires donc c'est un client qui se
respecte ce c'est quand même quelque
chose de très abondantes repart c'est un
pays qui a par le passé s'ils voulaient
rendu des services rappelez vous que
quand mitterrand en est à sa 3ème
d'évaluation on en voit d'autres misent
de l'économie et des finances en arabie
saoudite pour leur demander de partir et
là nous a avoué en des points de presse
pour éviter une troisième d'évaluation
donc c'est un pays avec lequel si vous
voulez encore une fois il faut réfléchir
à deux fois avant de prendre une
décision trop systématique et le fait
que la frôle un la guerre mondiale le
fait que le la presse ne parle pas de la
guerre au yémen
je vous signale qu'il ya 400 crise à la
surface de la planète la question c'est
pourquoi dans les rédactions on va
choisir tel critère guère que d'opter
lot
et effectivement la question ce n'est
pas vers vous c'est que vous voulez vous
faire au yémen vous dire si c'est une
espèce de pays que personne ne connaît
véritablement on a de très bons
spécialistes de la question
mais allez vous convaincre un patron de
journal de faire une sur la guerre au
yémen
non encore une fois c'est la dimension
médiatique qui fait l'importance d'une
guerre il faudrait engager auprès des
journaux pour la demander pourquoi la
garonne ne nous intéresse pas n'y a pas
d'image dont il n'y a pas d'image
il n'y a pas de faire la guerre au yémen
qui est pourtant l'une des pires crises
humanitaires selon l'onu merci en tout
cas pierre connais ça d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur france nous avoir
apporté votre analyse
et dans le reste de l'actualité nouvelle
journée de manifestations à alger près
de 2000 personnes ont décidé malgré
l'interdiction il manifestants ont
réussi à prendre le dessus sur les
policiers qui ont tenté de les repousser
scandant les slogans de l'irak
ils ont conspué le président seydoux de
cette reprise des mobilisations en
algérie survient paix en 15 mois d'arrêt
à cause de la pandémie et manifestants
appellent le gouvernement à rendre le
pouvoir au peuple
nous sommes aujourd'hui le 2 mars 2021
sur la place des martyrs à alger pour
continuer le combat pour obtenir
l'indépendance pour créer un état civil
et non militaire
nous sommes contre ce système qui a
maltraité les étudiants à l'université
et qui a marginalisé les jeunes ce qui a
poussé le peuple aujourd'hui à
manifester ce n'est pas le manque de
pain en ni les revendications sociales
et politiques
au contraire le peuple a décidé de se
soulever au nom de la liberté
après ce que les services de
renseignement ont fait au peuple
c'est une honte la répression policière
subies par le peuple est une honte pour
les institutions et l'état n'est pas
plat décidé de prendre la parole pour un
état civil et non militaire
et pour l'indépendance de l'algérie je
suis sorti aujourd'hui pour soutenir les
étudiants qui subissent des violences
policières dont je sortirai tous les
mardis et vendredis pour manifester
jusqu'au départ de ce gang
nos enfants sont au chômage et n'ont
rien ils ont volé et pillé l'argent
mais en tunisie à présent alors que de
nouvelles manifestations ont encore eu
lieu ce week-end pour réclamer de
meilleures conditions de vie les
habitants du nord ouest du pays semble
avoir perdu espoir
considéré comme la région la plus pauvre
leurs conditions de vie se dégradent
jour après jour les espoirs de la
révolution de 2011 sont désormais
lointain reportage dans la région de
jendouba de baisse m shelly est aisée
mais ce tri entre montagne et campagne
le nord-ouest de la tunisie semble être
figé dans un autre temps les habitants
de cette région considérée comme la plus
pauvre du pays ont souvent l'impression
d'être les grands oubliés du système
à 46 ans ali a perdu tout espoir dans sa
maison de fortune ils tentent tant bien
que mal de subvenir aux besoins de sa
femme et de ses deux enfants
en dépit des multiples promesses de
l'état d'améliorer ses conditions de vie
il semble aujourd'hui ne plus savoir
s'il est toujours tunisien dans un pays
où ses droits les plus élémentaires
semble n'être qu'un mirage s'arrête
des fois j'ai besoin de ma carte
d'identité pour me souvenir que je suis
tunisien
ce n'est qu'une nationalité pour moi car
car si j'étais réellement aux tunisiens
comme les autres j'aurai les mêmes
droits et moi je n'ai aucun droit
à commencer par le logement quand je
vois que certaines personnes vivent dans
un confort qui ne méritent pas je vois
que dans d'autres régions on aide
beaucoup la population
mais ici personne ne pense à nous et
quand tu vas demander ton du on te dit
qu'il n'y a rien pour le moment personne
ne t'écoute et on te dis simplement que
pour le moment il n'y a rien comment
voulez vous qu'on vive quand il parle de
sa région
il évoque un bout de territoire qui
n'intéresse les dirigeants qu en période
électorale avant de retomber dans
l'oubli
aussitôt les résultats annoncés dans ses
campagnes
c'est encore à dos d'âne que l'on
s'approvisionnent en eau à travers des
chemins escarpés et boueux en hiver qui
deviennent dangereux avec la neige
il ne faut pas moins de deux heures pour
atteindre la source dans les hauteurs
des montagnes voisines
le dénuement règne manque d'eau
d'infrastructures de transport ou encore
d'école et pour couronner le tout un
chômage qui grimpe ici à 30% selon
l'institut national des statistiques
j'ai 32 ans et je suis au chômage malgré
le fait que j'allais souvent à tunis
pour trouver du travail
ces populations vulnérables se
retrouvent très souvent dépourvus en
période d'intempéries ou face à la
maladie malika est né dans la région
quitté son village elle n'y songe pas
une minute
la révolution 2011 avaient suscité chez
elle de grands espoirs
mais dix ans après rien n'a changé il y
a deux ans sa fille de 25 ans a été
emporté par la maladie
en l'absence d'infrastructures médicales
locales beaucoup décède avant
d'atteindre l'hôpital le plus proche
quand ma fille a eu son attaque si
l'hôpital était proche elle aurait pu
être encore vivante aujourd'hui le temps
de trouver une voiture et de me rendre à
l'hôpital le plus proche
elle était déjà morte j'étais désespéré
et j'ai dû faire demi tour en voiture
avec ma fille morte dans les bras je
n'oublierai jamais ce jour alors comment
expliquer que cette région pourtant si
riche en ressources naturelles telles
que le bois l'aluminium le zinc ou
encore le phosphate soit en même temps
la plus pauvre du pays
et pourtant la région assure 60 % de la
production céréalière du pays et dispose
de 75 % des réserves d'eau du territoire
depuis tunis ou encore carthage les
politiques ont contribué et contribuent
encore à la paupérisation du nord-ouest
manci raoui et député indépendant de
jendouba le sort de sa région et depuis
toujours sa priorité est face à un
gouvernement qui ne s'intéresse qu'à la
carte électorale
il a parfois le sentiment de mener un
combat perdu d'avancé
pat
je pense que tous les gouvernements qui
se sont succédé ont fait l'impasse sur
les régions rurales
malgré le fait qu'on leur rappelle à
chaque fois leurs conditions précaires
le gouvernement ne semble travailler que
pour les intérêts de certaines grandes
familles qui détiennent le pays par leur
mainmise au détriment des populations
qui s'enfonce dans la pauvreté
la tristesse la fatigue et la précarité
en pleine crise politique
la tunisie se retrouve avec plus d'un
défi à relever à commencer par celui des
régions rurales qui se sentent depuis
longtemps laissés pour compte par tunis
et qui avait pourtant fait de grands
sacrifices pour la révolution de 2011 et
nourrit beaucoup d'espoirs dans la
démocratie tunisienne naissante
les retours en france à toulouse un
jeune étudiant en tacles et après avoir
été blessé en mai 2018 par l'explosion
d'une grenade de désencerclement lors de
son interpellation marge d'une opération
de police
reportage dans la ville rose signée
hervé grand champ avec jandy demory les
faits remontent au 9 mai 2018 et
l'évacuation des grévistes de
l'université jean jaurès par les forces
de l'ordre
ce jour-là guillem étudiant en lettres
et blessés par l'explosion d'une grenade
de désencerclement lors de son
interpellation devant la gare matabiau
de toulouse
concrètement je n'ai pas pu voir ce qui
se passait parce que j'étais maintenu
les deux bras et le regard fixé vers le
ciel je n'ai pu rien faire je peux même
pas me débattre donc j'ai pas pu voir ce
qui s'est passé concrètement tout ce que
je sais c'est que une grenade a explosé
dans mon dos sans que je ne comprenne
rien ce qui se passe et sans avoir
aucune explication de la raison de
l'explosion
j'aurais proches à l'état d'avoir armé
des policiers visiblement qui ne savent
pas se servir de leurs armes
ou alors qu'il s'en sert de façon que ce
sont de façon disproportionnée l'
affaire a été classée sans suite par le
parquet la responsabilité des policiers
écarté cette affaire est déjà passé
devant l'inspection générale de la
police nationale
les collègues ont été totalement
blanchis pour la bonne et simple raison
que c'etait un
un déclenchement accidentel de la
grenade qui a blessé et le monsieur en
question
guilhem et les deux autres
fonctionnaires votre haute fonction de
policier on ne comprend pas l'action de
ses avocats si ce n'est que c'est un
coup politique alors pourvue par les
deux géants on essaie de détourner ce
monsieur n'est n'est pas venu je crois
plus aux convocations de police à hilla
et et il a été il a été convoqué pur
faut pour être entendu il ne s'est
jamais rendu aux convocations
donc il ya quelque chose à se reprocher
si les policiers on était dédouané par
l'igpn les avocates de guillem ne compte
pas en rester là
ce qu'on espère c'est déjà que la
personne d'un guillaume soient
dédommagés qui puisse y avoir à nouveau
une expertise médicale pour refaire le
point sur la situation de guillem
ensuite des dommages et intérêts parce
que guillaume pour l'instant n'a pas été
indemnisé sur le préjudice subi qui est
très important à préjudice physique un
préjudice psychologique et on demande
aussi à ce que l'état réponde à ces
questions là c'est à dire en fait
l'agent judiciaire de l'état qui doit
répondre à nos questions à savoir est ce
que vous trouvez ça normal d'utiliser la
technique d'étranglement est ce que vous
trouvez ça normal de sortir une grenade
de désencerclement lorsqu'on est
policier judiciaire interpellateurs et
nous expliquer et bien comment ça
fonctionne
et pourquoi pourquoi ces permis et est
ce que là dessus l'état se questionne
sur ces méthodes là le jeune homme et
ses avocats espèrent obtenir des
dommages et intérêts mais aussi engager
la responsabilité de l'état
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur la réforme de
l'assurance chômage assoupli elles
restent contestés par les syndicats mais
en trois partiellement en vigueur le 1er
juillet et puis dans viendront sur la
situation sanitaire en france à la
veille d'un nouveau conseil de défense
sanitaire la campagne vaccinale va
accélérer mais jean castex mettant en
garde les semaines qui vont arriver vont
être difficiles
[Musique]
mon
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience du concert symphonique qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous un oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager c'est la part d'humanité
incontournable et indispensable à
l'évolution de tout être humain quand
vous entendez pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata pata papa papa pata
pata
vous avez envie de faire ça va aller il
faut que leur qu'istres groove la
musique c'est la traduction la plus
poétique de la vie si vous mettez pas la
vie des évidemment on s'embête il faut
sortir les notes de leurs univers
carcéral
mais il faut jouer ce qui a entre les
notes et avant tout c'est le rythme et
la pulsation et ça c'est fondamental
pour entraîner et l' enthousiasme des
musiciens et celui du public
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash vous parlerons de tout
sans langue de bois
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans va te suicider ça
ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que les gaffes à ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom est en ligne quel
rôle pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu et
big for donc les gaffes à s'organiser
pour annuler quelqu'un sur internet sur
quelqu'un c'était donald trump quand il
s'agit d'un bannissement si général pour
moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux
réseaux sociaux adoula des entreprises
privées de prendre cette décision mais
ça doit être à la justice de prendre
cette décision
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du technique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï pg les jeunes
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas là j'oublie
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
un certain regain de confiance est rompu
entre le politique et les experts même
les citoyens on est une société qui est
totalement percuté et on ne peut pas
considérer une démocratie vit
véritablement l'amplitude de ses
possibles et l'amplitude de ses valeurs
quand elle était à ce point confiné
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment on
repart à zéro par rapport à l'année
dernière
la société ne survivra pas à une
succession de confinement une société
c'est pas le confinement c'est la
liberté c'est la créativité c'est le
sentiment d'exister d'appartenir
comment on va réorganiser le monde il
est vrai que la pandémie c'est vivre
[Musique]
21h heure française merci de nous
rejoindre pour cette deuxième heure
d'émission tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité assoupli elle n'en
est pas moins rejeté par les syndicats
la réforme de l'assurance-chômage
entrera en vigueur partiellement le 1er
juillet annonce des syndicats
aujourd'hui à l'issue d'une ultime
séance de concertation avec le ministère
du travail
premier volet controversé de cette
réforme voulue par le gouvernement
un nouveau mode de calcul de
l'indemnisation des demandeurs d'emploi
est la veille d'un énième conseil de
défense sanitaire jean castex mettant en
garde les semaines qui arrivent vont
être difficile alors pour éviter un
nouveau confinement le gouvernement
accélère sa campagne de vaccination
pharmacie sages femmes infirmiers slim
est également astrazeneca désormais
étendu aux plus de 65 ans avec
comorbidités mais seuls 25% des doses
reçues de ce vaccin ont été utilisés
face à la pandémie mondiale certains
pays européens ont pris la décision
d'alléger les restrictions dans l'espoir
de relancer l'économie
les assouplissements qui contredisent la
tendance générale 6,25 millions de
français ne savent toujours pas s'ils
seront re confiné des week-ends les
allemands eux pourraient dès lundi
prochain reprendre certains contacts
sociaux
la chancelière angela merkel s'exprime
demain ce sujet
[Musique]
dernière réunion du gouvernement
aujourd'hui sur la réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui doit entrer
partiellement en vigueur le 1er juillet
la ministre du travail et des abeilles
bornes retrouver aujourd'hui une
dernière fois les partenaires sociaux
pour en discuter les principales
organisations syndicales et sont
pourtant fermement opposés compte rendu
de cette réunion avec sl farges devant
le ministère du travail coct vite 19
oblige son application a été reportée
par le gouvernement plusieurs fois mais
la réforme de l'assurance-chômage
entrera est bel et bien en vigueur du
moins partiellement
et cela au 1er juillet c'est en tout cas
ce qu'ont indiqué hé les syndicats ce
mardi à l'issue d'une ultime
concertation avec elisabeth bornes la
ministre du travail qui s'était dit je
cite et déterminés à aller au bout de
cette réforme une réforme oui mais
aménagé qui en période de crise
sanitaire et économique certaine mesure
dépendront de l'état de santé du marché
du travail slk par exemple être des
conditions est d'éligibilité aux
allocations ou encore la dégressivité de
la location pour ces deux mesures
il faudra à la fois une baisse du nombre
de chômeurs en catégorie à 230 milles
sur 6 mois et 2 7 millions d'embauchés
en plus sur quatre mois ces indicateurs
seront scrutés à partir du 1er avril
le fameux à système de bonus malus pour
les entreprises qui abusent des contrats
précaires lui sera appliquée en
septembre 2022 après une période
d'observation du comportement des
entreprises dans des secteurs qui ont
habituellement recours aux contrats
courts enfin le nouveau mode de calcul
du salaire journalier de référence
entrera lui en vigueur en juillet
prochain selon l'unedic 38% être des
allocataires devrait accuser une baisse
de leur allocation d'environ 20% du côté
des syndicats le compte n y est pas il
reste opposé à cette réforme injuste
anachronique incohérente est d
qui libres et qualificatifs par exemple
utilisée sur twitter par laurent berger
le patron de la cfdt est pour en parler
nous sommes avec benoît martin
secrétaire général cgt paris bonsoir
benoît martin merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france laurent berger
parle d'une réforme déséquilibré
c'est votre opinion aussi oui c'est
l'opinion de la cgt c'est l'opinion des
cinq organisations syndicales
représentatives dans notre pays donc cgt
cfdt fo cfe cgc et cftc
une partie de ces syndicats étaient
contre la réforme de penser en 2018 est
votée en 2019
mais depuis qu'il ya la crise due qu'au
guide et donc la situation nouvelle à
cette conjoncture nouvelle
du coup maintenant d'un front syndical
totalement unie contre cette réforme car
pour nous à la cgt c'est
structurellement pas une bonne réforme
et pour d'autres comme la cfdt ce n'est
pas la bonne le bon moment compte tenu
de la conjoncture mais pour une raison
ou pour une autre nous y sommes tous et
toutes organisations syndicales
opposés à cette réforme qui pourrait
prendre effet au 1er juillet par un
décret du gouvernement qui surviendrait
dès le 1er avril
alors vous êtes en pleine crise
sanitaire effectivement les discussions
relancé aujourd'hui un petit peu
anachronique peut-être oui c'est
anachronique
bon déjà la philosophie de la réforme
pose est largement problème ça c'est
consiste à culpabiliser les chômeurs il
ya aujourd'hui six millions de demandes
d'emplois toutes catégories a b c d e
voilà donc si on ajoute les précaires
les gens qui sont tour disparu des
radars qui sont même plus demandeurs
d'emploi mais qui sont par exemple ou au
rsa ou autre on a un quart de la
population active qui est dans le
chômage ou la précarité aujourd'hui dans
notre pays donc vouloir aggraver non
seulement le montant des indemnités
chômage pour les chômeurs
et puis également les conditions d'accès
à cette indignation du chômage ce n'est
vraiment pas une bonne idée ça va jeter
des gens encore des milliers de gens
dans la pauvreté dans la précarité des
gens vont payer leur loyer d'être est
exclu de leur logement etc
donc c'est vraiment on se demande
vraiment que cette réforme soit
abandonné benoît martin elle a été tout
de même assoupli vous avez été peut-être
en partie rejeté en partie entendu ça ne
suffisait pas les concessions n'étaient
pas assez importantes
non ce n'est pas ce n'est pas suffisant
parce que quand même dans l'est avec la
nouvelle donne aujourd'hui un suite à
cette cette table ronde qui a eu lieu
sous forme de visioconférence à l'antre
entre la ministre bornes et les
organisations syndicales et patronales
à l'issue de cette réunion dont on en
est mais toujours dans une situation où
pour accéder à l'indemnisation chômage
il faudra avoir travaillé six mois et
non plus quatre mois comme quatre mois
aujourd'hui
et puis d'autre part on a à peu près 38%
des indemnisés au chômage qui gagneront
20% de moins d'indemnités et donc c'est
vraiment inacceptable
alors on imagine en plus qu'avec la
crise sanitaire eh bien il ya des
conséquences
il ya des contrats courts plus peut-être
voilà de souplesse de petits contrats ça
va aussi peser encore davantage
oui ça va peser car justement pour
accéder à la démonisation du chômage
seront lisez en particulier les
intérimaires les travailleurs
saisonniers
les intermittents ceux qui font des
extras dans les amicalement dans les
contient des événements où il est dans
la restauration l'hôtellerie etc
donc tout ça est arrêté en ce moment on
pourra accéder à oublier du chômage ça
va être empêchée pour des milliers de
gens dans notre pays donc c'est vraiment
si surtout pas le moment de surpasser
c'est très fort alors c'est une réforme
on le rappelle qui visait à réaliser de
1 à 1,3 milliard d'économies par an en
durcissant donc les règles
d'indemnisation vous l'avez dit vous
estimez quand même qu'il est nécessaire
de rétablir cet équilibre de l'assurance
chômage
sur le fond en tout cas le diagnostic
est ce que vous en convenez oui mais
pour retrouver l'équilibré
si ça se fera surtout en faisant baisser
le chômage
alors c'est vrai que là on est dans une
période où vient d'accumuler 10
milliards de déficit selon l'unedic
donc c'est sait jamais une bonne chose
d'être trop endettés d'autant plus que
c'est l'unedic qui devra porter le poids
de la dette en europe est porté par la
cades est ce qui est la caisse
d'amortissement de la dette sociale
un taux de avec des taux d'emprunt qui
sont inférieures qui sont ceux de l'état
en fait mais là l'unedic devoir payer
une remboursement de la dette plus
importante mais en fait effectivement on
est en crise économique et donc il ya
des guerres un choix à faire
soit on s'endette pour poursuivre cette
indemnisation des chômeurs ou alors on
plonge des milliers de gens dont l'un
aurait trop pauvre tu es la précarité ou
qu'il vaut mieux s'endetter un peu et
puis voilà assuré quand même un revenu
aux gens si quand même également une
bonne chose pour la consommation qui a
monté un moteur extrêmement important
pour pouvoir retrouver la croissance
alors c'est vrai que quand on vous
écoute et quand on lit un petit peu les
contours de cette réforme on se rend
compte que la situation va effectivement
se durcir pour les chômeurs comment vous
vous expliquer qui est pas plus de
revendications même de manifestations y
compris dans la rue contre cette réforme
parce que tout simplement la crise
sanitaire inhibe tout cela et cela passe
un petit peu inaperçu alors le sujet
avec une émission comme la vôtre
en ce moment ça permet d'en parler mais
c'est vrai que c'est un peu perdus quand
même donné dans les informations
générales entre sarkozy la crise du coc
vide et c'est peut-être pas assez de
l'enjeu de la mobilisation des des
chômeurs et c'est vrai que certaines
personnes qui voudraient manifester ne
font peut-être un peu moins en ce moment
en raison des risques sanitaires et puis
brigade couvre feu quand même pas
évident dans les musées sa vie et puis
la lutte en même temps mais ceci dit
après demain jeudi le jeudi 4 donc mars
il y aura une manifestation du monde du
spectacle qui sont très concernés
notamment les intermittents du spectacle
cette question de l'indemnisation des
temps non travaillé
donc ils seront aux manifestations à
paris à partir de 12h à république pour
aller vers madeleine et puis la semaine
prochaine nous organisons devant le
ministère du travail donc ce sera le 9
mars à partir de 11 heures un
rassemblement syndical pour protester
contre cette réforme de la limitation
aux chômeurs merci beaucoup en tout cas
benoît martin secrétaire général cgt
paris d'avoir été avec nous pour nous
parler de cette réforme de l'assurance
chômage
sur le front de la crise sanitaire
veille d'un conseil de défense sanitaire
jean castex met en garde les semaines
qui arrivent vont être difficiles une
déclaration tempéré par gabriela talent
qui évoque une lumière au bout du tunnel
avec la vaccination
les précisions de mona un mot dès lors
depuis l'elysée le gouvernement veut
passer à la vitesse supérieure alors que
seuls les médecins pouvaient vacciner la
haute autorité de la santé recommande
que les pharmaciens les infirmiers ou
encore et les sages-femmes puisse
administrer tous les vaccins confondus à
savoir l astra zeneca l'eau moderna ou
encore l'oeuf either premièrement
l'objectif est d'étendre la charge de
travail pour aller au plus vite et
vacciner un maximum de français et puis
à diversifier le profil des vaccinateurs
multiplier les lieux de vaccination pour
finalement la simplifier et puis selon
elle la haute autorité et de la santé
les pharmaciens pourraient même
prescrire des vaccins anti qu'ovide
d'alors concernant ces vaccins s'il
astrazeneca était un peu le mal aimé des
vaccins anti qu'ovide pour les 65 75 ans
c'est parce que les autorités sanitaires
manqué de données efficaces concernant
un public âgé mais une étude écossaise
ses biens a fait pencher la balance en
sa faveur et d'après cette étude
écossaise et bien
le vaccin astrazeneca aurait une
efficacité comparable au vaccin
father sur un nombre élevé de patients
âgés
le vaccin britannique est presque en
train d'inverser la tendance c'est ce
qui a confirmé olivier ferrand le
ministre de la santé écoutez le la haute
autorité de santé considère désormais
depuis aujourd'hui que tous les vaccins
dont nous disposons en france le
astrazeneca le finder et le modern art
où une efficacité qualifié de
remarquable est désormais le vaccin
astrazeneca va être étendu aux 65 75 ans
atteint de comorbidité soit 2,5 millions
de français
écouter à nouveau le ministre de la
santé désormais les personnes âgées de
50 ans et plus incluant les 65 75 ans
qui souffre de ce qu'on appelle des
comorbidités des fragilités pourront se
faire vacciner avec astrazeneca chez
leur médecin traitant dans l'hôpital qui
les suit ou dans quelques jours en
pharmacie je peux acté que désormais
toutes les personnes de 50 ans et plus
qui ont des fragilités peuvent se faire
vacciner avec le vaccin astrazeneca sans
limite d'âge
à la veille du conseil sanitaire de
défense s'il n'y a pas d'amélioration
dans les vingt sept départements placés
sous surveillance et l'exécutif va
devoir envisager un nouveau tour de vis
à la veille et de ce conseil le
gouvernement travaille sur plusieurs
mesures concrètes et ciblées par exemple
un confinement
le week end mais pour l'instant rien
n'est sûr plusieurs scénarios sont en
discussion et les décisions seront donc
prises en fonction et des concertations
et surtout en fonction de l'évolution de
l'épidémie et dans le sillage de la
pandémie
des drames personnels des gestionnaires
d'établissements de santé qui
interdisent aux proches de visiter des
patients atteints du coc vite dans les
derniers jours de leur vie
une situation que dénonce notamment
laurent vraiment qui a perdu son père au
mois de novembre dans des circonstances
dans ces circonstances il est avec nous
pour en témoigner
bonsoir laurent vraiment merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
dans une tribune poignante 1 publié le
10 février dans marianne vous dis pour
ma volée la mort de mon père vous
dénoncez ce que malheureusement beaucoup
de familles vivent pendant cette crise
sanitaire que s'est il passé
eh bien mon père a été hospitalisé pour
être soignée jusqu'aux villes et
d'anglais on nous a interdit de visite
et au bout d'une semaine il s'est
réveillé il n'était plus contaminés mais
eu jusqu'à trois tests négatifs et pour
autant nous a encore interdits de visite
nous a bloqués à l'entrée deux au
service et en augmentant son état de
santé
parce que on lui disait qu'il allait
mieux mais en réalité il avait attrapé
une infection nosocomiale dans ce
service qui fait qu' il est décédé
malheureusement et finalement les
médecins nous ont rappelé que deux fois
la première fois pour nous dire de ne
pas trop la plaie vaut ne pas le
déranger et la seconde pour dénoncer la
mort de mon père alors plus peut-être
que le problème d'une relation avec un
médecin et c'est en ce sens que votre
témoignage et est intéressant c'est tout
un protocole que vous dénoncez un
protocole finalement appliqué avec
aveuglement sans humanité
c'est bien cela voilà en fait on se
réfugie derrière un protocole qui est
tout simplement inhumain et qui n'a
insiste aucun fondement juridique donc
des des gestionnaires d'établissements
et des médecins profitent de la
situation au finalement exercer une
sorte de contrôle sur leurs patients et
sur leurs familles et je dénonce en
particulier c'est l'accès aux eaux corps
à la dépouille d de nos malades
aujourd'hui qui est rendu au post qui a
rendu impossible par de nombreux chefs
d'établissement qui finalement
privilégie la mise en bière immédiate
qui fait que de nombreuses familles sont
aujourd'hui privés de des derniers mois
entre clément autour de leurs des gens
donc ça veut dire concrètement laurent
vraiment que vous n'avez pu voir
votre papa
pendant sa maladie donc il des morts en
quelque sorte nous sommes loin de ses
proches et que vous n'avez pas tous le
voir non plus après avant qu'on l'en
terre voilà donc les mains dans une
solitude la plus absolue la plus totale
sans pouvoir nous voir une dernière fois
sans pouvoir parler et évidemment nous
n'avons pas pu le revoir avant sa mise
en bière
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous vous
ressentez de la tristesse de la colère
en mélange un mélange peut-être des deux
sentiments mais évidemment une très
grande tristesse à un traumatisme
considérable de perdre son père dans des
conditions aussi affreuse pas pouvoir
lui dire au revoir de ne pas pouvoir
faire ses adieux à son visage mais aussi
un peu de colère vis-à-vis d'un système
qui a laissé ce genre de situation
prospérer dans l'impunité la plus totale
donc j'essaie de transcender cette
colère elle a transformé aujourd'hui en
actions positives pour que ce genre de
situation la plus plus se produire parce
qu'il ya encore aujourd'hui des milliers
de familles qui sont bloqués à l'entrée
des services qui réclament désespérément
de voir leurs proches
je pense notamment aux ehpad aussi aux
hôpitaux et aux cliniques
donc il faut que cette situation cesse
d'urgence je me coupe parce que je vais
vous laisser poursuivre et c'est
important de le signaler et vous c'était
dans une clinique privée vous vous dites
que ça revient au même à l'ap-hp aux
hôpitaux publics dans les ehpad c'est le
même combat c'est ce sont les mêmes
protocoles mêmes règles qui s'appliquent
exactement là on reçoit des milliers de
témoignages des personnes qui ont vécu
ce genre de situation tragique et c'est
de manière indifférenciée dans le public
et dans le privé
même si dans ces établissements il ya
souvent des équipes admirable qui font
tout pour permettre l'accès aux patients
et à fortiori aux mourants mais
malheureusement ce genre de situation
est observée dans tous types
d'établissements et donc c'est une
situation indigne qui fait reculer notre
humanité notre civilisation est donc
j'aimerais y mettre fin le plus
rapidement possible laurent vraiment
clairement à quoi vous attribuez
cela parce qu'on parle souvent ici même
du manque de moyens des hôpitaux d'aidé
soignant il y as peut-être de ceux là
aussi on applique des règles qui peuvent
paraître extrêmement inhumaine et elles
le sont quand on vous écoute bien
évidemment mais peut-être aussi faute de
moyens parce qu'on ne peut pas aussi
gérer les les proches de ces patients
mais ce serait trop facile de désigner
un coupable
je pense que nous sommes finalement tous
un peu coupable de cette situation parce
que nous avons laissé le monde de la
santé
dérivé peu à peu depuis des années vers
un système de plus en plus inhumain qui
est fondée aujourd'hui uniquement sur la
rentabilité sur des considérations de
gestionnaire et non plus sur des
considérations liées à l'humain à ce
qu'y fait la personne c'est-à-dire le
lien avec les autres
le contact tout ce qui entoure en fait
notre existence et donc certes on peut
déplorer un manque de moyens il me
semble que dans une société qui se dit
progressiste avancées pourraient au
moins des blocs et débloqué des fonds
pour pouvoir équiper les familles et
nouméa au moins un référent par
établissement qui puisse donner des
nouvelles aux proches ça me semble
vraiment basique on a un pays qui se
prétend qui se prétend avance avancée
mais qui finalement laisse mourir des
gens dans la solitude la plus totale et
ça c'est inadmissible mais jeu mais je
le répète
certes il ya des gestionnaires qui ont
abusé de leur petit pouvoir mais nous
sommes finalement tous responsables de
cette situation parce que finalement la
crise du covin n'est que le révélateur
de dysfonctionnements scandaleux qui ont
lieu depuis des années aux petits soins
de santé aujourd'hui clairement vous en
appelez à l'état et bien aujourd'hui les
gestionnaires qui bloque les visites
profil d'une sorte de vide juridique
c'est à dire que leur laisse la
permission d'interdire lé v de la visite
et donc il y en a qui en abusent donc ce
que je propose c'est d'instaurer un
droit opposable aux visites pour pour
que les familles qui se voit refuser un
but
fermant l'accès à leurs proches puissent
saisir le juge des référés en urgence
pour contraindre ces établissements à
ouvrir leurs portes
c est ce serait une manière aussi pour
gouvernement de rattraper des mois
d'inhumanité parce que cette situation
dure depuis mars
c'est autant de violations a montré à
notre humanité
et bien ce serait pour le gouverneur au
gouvernement un moyen de se rattraper et
finalement de compenser ces mois
d'inaction parce que dans le discours
officiel
on voit bien que le présent dans le
public comme le milieu de la santé
déclare que les visites doivent être
autorisées mais dans les faits il laisse
aujourd'hui des gestionnaires se
comportait de manière arbitraire et je
dirais même dictatorial merci beaucoup
en tout cas c'est vraiment pour votre
témoignage et bon courage à vous merci
merci son geste avait été largement
médiatisé et même relayé à
l'international jean michel rey le
gérant du dojo 114 de bruges en gironde
et décidé d'interrompre sa grève de la
faim au bout de trois semaines
il revient sur son combat c'est une
exclusivité rt france récit de meximieux
étiez sur des images de renault parquet
le geste est fort symbolique après 21
jours de grève de la faim jean michel
rey a décidé de se réalimenter pendant
trois semaines il a voulu alerter les
autorités en cessant de se nourrir pour
bénéficier d'une aide financière
équivalant à trois mois de loyer pour
permettre à son dojo de continuer à
accueillir des associations sportives
avant de commencer la grève de la faim
et je me suis j'ai voulu discuter et
dialoguer expliquer notre problème on a
envoyé des centaines de courriels
personne ne me répondait que contraint
et forcé comme je suis une tête de mule
on dire autre chose à bordeaux j'ai dit
c'était la seule solution parce que
c'est mon bébé ça partira pas si large
part avec lui il a écrit jusqu'au sommet
de l'état
seule brigitte macro et nicolas dupont
aignan lui ont manifesté leur soutien
s'il est vrai qu'il n'avait pas demandé
des aides à la mairie jusqu'à très
récemment
ce gérant s'est très vite senti
abandonné ce cri d'alarmé à semble-t-il
été entendu
du côté de la mairie de bruges nous
avons prévu d'aller jeudi matin le
rencontrer faire avec lui le point sur
sur les dossiers qui est qu'il a entamée
et lui apporter tous les dossiers
administratifs nécessaires pour que
ensemble on monte on fasse les dossiers
pour auprès de la métropole de du
département de la région et de la
municipalité pour kiel pour qu'on puisse
le venir en aide
la municipalité a débloqué au total près
de 40000 euros de fonds pour permettre à
la centaine d'associations de la ville
de redémarrer leur activités espéré dès
le mois de septembre
jean michel lui ne croit que ce qu'il
voit si ces promesses ne sont pas tenues
il projette déjà une action plus forte
encore rester avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons des écoles elles
ne doivent pas être fermé elle ne doit
être fermée qu'en dernier recours pardon
une exception française dont il y a tout
lieu d'être fiers expliqué ce matin le
ministre de l'éducation nationale et
puis nous ferons un point sur le conflit
dans l'europe les allemands pourraient
dès lundi prochain en europe
en certains contacts sociaux la
chancelière angela merkel s'exprime
demain à ce sujet
[Musique]
donc
jordan barre de la et marion maréchal-le
pen qui dénonce cette censure pour eux
facebook menaçant fait d'eux des publier
des pages de soutien mouvement
génération identitaire il faut en finir
avec cette dérive dégâts femmes il faut
rappeler la primauté du droit français
sur le territoire national des pouvoirs
publics en france et dans d'autres pays
sont un peu tétanisé face aux géants du
numérique
moi j'ai eu l'occasion il ya quelques il
ya deux ans au parlement européen d'
interpeller
mark zuckerberg le pdg de facebook sur
cette question il avait d'ailleurs un
produit de manière très alambiquée mais
je crois que ça nécessite maintenant que
les pouvoirs publics se saisissent du
sujet ils défendent la liberté
d'expression et s'ils ne le font pas et
bien et ce conflit
oh
[Musique]
la crise sanitaire pourrait creuser
encore un peu plus les inégalités entre
les plus riches et les plus pauvres il
ya un million de pauvres en plus on est
passé de 9 à 10 millions de pauvres
on a 20 % des français qui ne mangent
pas à leur faim nous ne sommes pas en
france on a l'impression d'être en train
de passer dans un pays du tiers-monde le
problème il est bien en amont les depuis
que les banques centrales
intrigues de l'argent et quand l intérim
de l'argent en fait ça ne va pas dans
l'économie réelle
ça va juste sur les marchés financiers
la cause de la paupérisation de la
france de la tiers-mondisation sur la
glande s'engage si la destruction de
l'industrie française réindustrialiser
c'est pas juste en claquant des doigts
vous faites revenir les sociétés d'abord
il faut changer complètement tout c'est
à dire tout ce qui les a fait partir il
ya une débauche d'argent qu'on met sur
le sur la table sans se préoccuper de
savoir qui au final va payer au final
c'est toujours les mêmes les dindons de
la farce c'est toujours les mêmes vers
qui on va se tourner pour aller payer la
note
et
la minus là et compte au moins quatorze
mille militaires et policiers déployés
au mali ou non s'est elle fasse c'est
une mission de paix de la chose unis
mais la vérité c'est qu'elle évolue dans
un environnement difficile quand on vend
un ennemi un ennemi invisible
un ennemi qui ne connaît pas de
frontières qui nous premier cas la
brutalité qui est là pour faire du mal
mais grâce à notre détermination nous
sommes très différents
on a le sentiment c'est une guerre
perpétuelle dans le sahel contre les
terroristes quel est votre constat la
menace et le risque d'une menace globale
et que sa réponse également doit être
plus souvent la de la solidarité
robin
et il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple accepter
une volonté collectés vous le savez pour
moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y a pas
d'alternative on s'en doutait il est
clair que tout le monde attend ça est-ce
que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
m
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la louve
ligue parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
vous insistez beaucoup sur l'aspect des
dépenses publiques ce que je critique
c'est que on est dans un état
d'addiction de grande dépendance à la
dépense publique je ne veux pas du sang
et des larmes leçons et lamont les actes
et j'ai trop de dépenses trop d'état je
pense en tout cas qu'il ya trop de
bureaucratie c'est à dire un état
inefficace tout ça a été financée
essentiellement par de la dette
le problème est moins la dette en
réalité moi je pense qu'on remboursera
la dette par la croissance donc il faut
essayer de libérer l'économie française
et notamment le travail
notre problème en france c'est un
problème où la dépense publique est
excessive
mais surtout elle n'est pas productive
les français n'en ont pas pour leur
argent
de ce point de vue emmanuel macron n'a
rien changé par exemple par rapport à
son prédécesseur françois hollande
[Musique]
21h30 heure de paris soit il est
bienvenu si vous nous rejoignez en
direct sur rt france les écoles ne
doivent être fermées qu'en tout dernier
recours les maintenir ouvertes
constituent une exception française dont
il ya lieu d'être fiers expliqué ce
matin en substance le ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer air au micro de france inter
pour parler de ces écoles et les armes
déployées face au co vide nous sommes
avec alexis poulain c'est notre rubrique
l'édito bonsoir alexis poulain remercier
d'être soit avec nous rentrée des
classes donc jean-michel blanquer qui
détaille un plan de test parfois un
petit peu difficile à suivre
oui on voit bien que c'est la rentrée
qui est préparé avec amateurisme avec
fierté et dans l'improvisation la plus
totale un peu comme d'habitude bon on a
l'habitude depuis un an j'ai envie de
dire puisqu'il a été annoncé les tests
salivaires sur les élèves pour voir
s'ils étaient porteurs de différents
variant ou pas sauf que qui va faire les
tests salivaires les syndicats de
professeurs s'en sont émus les médecins
et infirmiers scolaires également alors
jean michel blanquer a repris la parole
ces derniers jours pour dire bien il y
aura un recrutement de 1700 médiateur
qui sont des étudiants pharmaciens
médecins en santé ou ou non qui vont
faire ces gestes pour tester les élèves
l'idée c'est de passer de dix mille
tests par semaine actuellement alors il
s'agit de tests salivaires beaucoup
moins intrusif que les tests pcr et de
monter jusqu'à 300 mille tests par
semaine à la mi mars
c'est vraiment une organisation qui pose
encore beaucoup de questions sur la fois
le recrutement de ces médiateurs
est-ce que ça fait partie du dispositif
un jeune une solution alors jean michel
blanquer radics oui ces emplois seront
payés on ne sait pas combien tout ça est
vraiment inventé au jour le jour pour
répondre à cette crise sanitaire puisque
comme vous l'avez dit le quoi qu'il en
coûte pour jean michel blanquer
c'est de ne surtout pas fermer les
écoles c'est l'exception française et il
y tient pour lui la continuité
pédagogique est le plus important
et puis il ya bien sûr les merci aux
médecins scolaires aux professeurs qui
ont reçu une prime de 150 euros pour
s'équiper en informatique c'est très peu
comparé aux prix actuellement des biens
informatiques et numériques
et puis la prime d'attractivité de 100
euros par mois qui commencera à être
versés pour les professeurs les plus
jeunes à partir du mois de mai donc on
voit bien que l'objectif fondamental de
jean michel blanquer air est de garder
les écoles ouvertes pour ce faire il va
falloir faire beaucoup de tests
on attend de voir si le pari va être
tenu dans les semaines qui viennent
oui pour jean michel blanquer donc le
quoi qu'il en coûte c'est de ne pas
fermer des écoles sauf en dernier
recours oui c'est exactement ça et alors
le jeu quoi qu'il en coûte
il est étrange parce que la france
finalement est à contretemps des voisins
européens qui avaient choisi eux de
fermer les écoles au mois de janvier en
début d'année pour éviter justement la
propagation des variants anglais
brésiliens et autres qui se commençait à
venir partout sur le territoire européen
c'est le choix entre différents de la
france de dire nous devons rester
ouverts et c'est en dernier recours que
nous fermerons pour éviter une
catastrophe éducative
il s'agit de suivre les recommandations
de l'exécutif qui a choisi une approche
territorialisée localiser avec
déconfinement le week-end on l'a vu sur
le littoral avec ce couvre-feu à 18
heures qui est censé selon jérôme
salomon porté ses fruits et remettra un
modèle pour d'autres partenaires
européens qui regarde la france avec
envie et pourtant jean michel blanquer
redit il faut voir effectivement la
relation entre avantages et
inconvénients de fermeture des classes
alors c'est la doctrine bien sûr de dire
nous ne fermerons des classes en france
seulement s'il y a trois cas de variant
angles est avérée et lorsqu'il ya un cas
de variants sud africain où un cas de
variants brésiliens qui sont des
variants beaucoup plus contagieux
le problème en france c'est que on va
peut-être faire des tests salivaires
mais malheureusement on ne fait pas
assez de séquençage c'est ce qui permet
de savoir en fait en temps réel quels
sont les variants qui circulent sur le
territoire nous on fait en fait des
petits drop pour savoir à quel moment
tous les quinze jours
quels sont les variants aujourd'hui
c'est le variés anglais qui est le plus
disséminé qui est en train de prendre le
dessus sur les autres mais on voit bien
que si on garde les écoles ouvertes
évidemment que ça risque
de circuler à vive allure on est loin du
compte
pour jean-michel bancaire pourtant ils
lisent et les élèves et les enfants
respectent davantage les gestes barrière
à l'école qu'en vacances par exemple où
il dit que les contaminations seraient
plus nombreuses ça reste à voir
là encore les études sont
contradictoires et puisqu'on parle
d'école alexis quid de la vaccination
des professeurs et des enseignants est
bien là encore pas de stratégie
particulière de l'exécutif
sauf de dire que les professeurs de plus
de 50 ans avec des comorbidités vont
pouvoir se faire vacciner immédiatement
pour les autres eh bien ils devront
attendre que les classes d'âge soit
ouverte à la vaccination il n'y a pas de
stratégie pour choisir des publics
particuliers prioritaires que sont les
professeurs les métiers de contact les
soignants là encore il faudra simplement
attendre que les doses arrive puisque on
manque toujours deux doses et aussi que
la logistique arrive à suivre
aujourd'hui par exemple astrazeneca
n'est pas distribué de nombreuses doses
du vaccin astrazeneca dorment dans les
frigos en france et puis comme ce vaccin
bien finalement on arrive pas à
l'administrer à la vitesse qui avait été
annoncé on commence à parler des
traitements contre le coronavirus
c'était ce que disait olivier verrons
lors de sa conférence de presse jeudi
dernier la france a décidé d'utiliser
ces traitements d'anticorps monoclonaux
produits par le laboratoire eli lilly
laboratoire américain médicaments
s'appelle le bam la nive imams assez
imprononçable et les résultats de ce
médicament sont contestées là encore il
ya eu un peu la précipitation du
gouvernement français c'est un
traitement très cher de 1000 à 2000
euros la dose mais la france a commandé
parce que l'allemagne en avait commandé
environ deux cent mille doses et puis il
faut savoir que au sein du comité de
direction dit lily en france la
responsable notamment de l'accès au
marché des nouveaux produits bien est
une proche des premiers cercles du parti
la république en marge du parti des
modèles mâcon est ce là encore un
conflit d'intérêts en perspective
l'avenir nous le dira et puis il y a les
déclarations du chef de l'état hier à
stains devant des jeunes qui a dit il
faut encore tenir ensemble pour environ
quatre à six semaines
alors on ne sait pas d'où il tient sa
jean castex a expliqué il a remis une
couche aujourd'hui en disant oui vous
savez avec le climat et la vaccination
qui continue peut-être que
on va en sortir d'ici quelques semaines
mais les semaines devant nous pour être
les plus difficiles est clairement
aujourd'hui les français n'ont pas de
cap
on reste devant un horizon bouché sans
date sans savoir comment cette crise de
coronavirus doit être gérée dans les
semaines qui viennent et la suite aucune
date de réouverture des restaurants des
lieux de culture des cinémas tout est en
impesanteur finalement on est suspendu à
au conseil de défense chaque semaine il
y en a 1 demain matin c'est peut-être le
conseil de défense de la dernière chance
pour éviter art confinement parce que
emma daumas qu'on a choisi de ne pas re
confiné si jamais ça devait arriver ce
serait un camouflet assez sévère pour le
chef de l'état
donc si jamais on confine ce sera
localement et avec un autre vocabulaire
sans doute pour ne pas contredire entre
le mac merci alexis poulain peut être un
début de réponse à demain pour la énième
conférence
voilà exactement merci alexis poulain
merci d'avoir été avec nous et depuis
hier soir minuit les seize mille
travailleurs frontaliers de la moselle
doivent montrer patte blanche pour se
rendre en allemagne berlin a placé le
territoire à haut risque pour passer la
frontière les passagers doivent
présenter un test pcr ou antigénique
négative de moins de 48 heures pas de
quasi fermeture comme avec la république
tchèque et le tyrol autrichien
jean rottner le président a l'air de la
région grand est ce combat de cette
décision écouter on a été surpris à la
fois de la soudaineté et de la brutalité
de cette décision
on essayait de bâtir quelque chose
d'inédit au niveau d'un espace de
coopération européen et on se fait
rattraper par une position qui est
plutôt une position centrale allemande
les chiffres de la moselle aujourd'hui
sont stables et pour en parler nous
sommes avec fabien defilippo députés l
ère de la 4e circonscription de moselle
bonsoir fait bien défini pour merci
d'être avec nous en direct par téléphone
quelle est votre réaction à cette
décision soudaine comme l'a décrit jean
rottner wii était plus lente entre qu'il
ya deux choses dans ma vie stable
effectivement la semaine clé de cette
décision et le tronc bilatéralisme qui
met à mal la coopérative était dans tout
le temps d'avoir avec les länder présent
puisque une famille donne
three frontalière donc avec une femme
travaillant beaucoup il ya énormément
des changes avec le luxembourg avec
l'aca avec le deuil dure quand même
beaucoup beaucoup de chance pour sur
notre territoire c'est très important
et la deuxième chose qu'il faut quand
même souligner est aussi le rôle du
gouvernement parce qu'aujourd'hui le
gouvernement joue les vierges
effarouchées face à cette décision
allemande mais il ne faut pas oublier
que olivier v man puis jean castex enfin
beaucoup stigmatiser la moselle en
soulignant tout maintenant qu'il était
vraiment mais peu de points que
l'arrivée des variants on a beaucoup
plus pauvres tel que dans d'autres
départements donc mécaniquement le taux
d'incidence kader le nombre de cas
positifs rapporté à la population est
très élevé les tigres comme l autre de
possibilité d'un modèle est à dire le
pourcentage de tête qui sont positifs
sur le nombre de tests effectués il
n'est encore - bellevue en modèle en
moyenne dans les autres départements
donc il ne faut pas stigmatiser la
beauté espagnole a forcément et bien
rondes ont fait des autres et des boucs
émissaires du président de catherine
territoire on écrit beaucoup de
difficultés pour nos travailleurs alors
qu'aujourd'hui la situation sanitaire le
justifient absolument pas absolument
plus alors les restrictions tout cas
elles sont quand même copieusement on
rappelle que ces concerne 16 mille
travailleurs frontaliers test de
dépistage négative de -2 48 heures et de
déclarations électroniques d'entrer
enfin c'est surtout pour que le test que
c'est compliqué
comment ça va se gérer
tout cela est d'ailleurs avec un coup
j'imagine faramineux aussi pour les
tailles de sécurité sociale oui il y à
ses obligations de test et tout n'était
pas encore à la dernière minute d'accord
bienvenue en pratique on a vu déjà
obligé de patienter longuement à la à la
frontière il y a eu des négociations sur
le dd des tests d'avant il a fallu faire
pression sur le gouvernement pour qu'il
parte notre voie et que les tests ne
soient pas détruits
24' effectué tous les jours nous demande
et 72 apporte ne sera fait que deux fois
par cet été trouvé pour que ce soit 48
heures fort heureusement parce que comme
vous l'avez dit déjà pour les gens c'est
hyper contraignant de trouver un créneau
pour faire un tête tous les deux jouent
les en plus c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement d' extrêmement coûteux
donc aujourd'hui il ya un certain nombre
de tests et antigénique et ça monte et
ça libère peut-être un moment donné qui
vont être mises en place aux frontières
mais force est de constater
qu'effectivement une bonne partie du
coût repose là sur nous on de la
sécurité sociale mais aussi en partie un
moment donné sur les sur les frappes
aériennes sur les travailleurs eux-mêmes
la population à ces travailleurs fabien
di filippo comment ils réagissent
aujourd'hui on imagine beaucoup
d'incompréhension et de colère beaucoup
d'incompréhension alors la colère
maintenant avec les mois les mesures
sanitaires curité imposé on a dit de la
moselle
elle a cédé la place petit à petit à la
résignation sans beaucoup de résignation
et d'agacement des jantes mais
effectivement il était déjà à cran ils
le sont comme un petit peu plus parce
que vous l'avez dit les travailleurs
frontaliers dans un département comme le
note 16000 personnes qui m'ont en
allemagne tous les jours n'est pas n'est
pas une mince affaire
donc il sort à la fois agacé mais aussi
d'un certain côté un peu résignés par
cette histoire du coc vide qui dure qui
dure
et pour ces gens qui travaillent encore
la perspective d'être vacciné de pouvoir
reprendre une vie normale et par les
choix qui sont faits en france et la
stratégie vaccinale un peu identique
elle est en plus elle est renvoyée à
plusieurs mois devant nous donc ceux des
chefs formés à durer dans les wagons
alors on assemble
l'impression alors c'est peut-être une
impression vous allez me corriger que
finalement nous on est plutôt assez
clément assez souple et que c'est à
l'étranger que c'est le plus compliqué
bien qu'on soit évidemment en europe on
le rappelle qu'en est il des allemands
qui viennent chez nous les travailleurs
allemands rien à peut-être moi je ne
sais pas mais eux ils sont soumis à des
restrictions aussi drastiques
non bien sûr que non il y en a moins
mais ils sont quand même mais ils sont
quand même là et puis pour compléter
optima réponse à la question précédente
vous savez on a l'habitude dans notre
région de vivre les uns avec les autres
les économies sont imbriquées beaucoup
de gens pour certains produits viennent
d'allemagne faire leurs courses en
france et à linverse pour d'autres
produits les rentrées vont faire leurs
courses en allemagne
donc nous visons les uns avec les autres
de manière interdépendantes et et un
briquet donc la france mais depuis le
début de la crise a souvent par rapport
à à ses frontières ses preuves dans g10
n'a jamais voulu le remettre en cause a
beaucoup de moments qui étaient les
facilités de de schengen même comme ça
nous était défavorable et que au
printemps de l'année dernière le virus
monte monte très très vite et on se rend
compte et bien que les allemands sont
plutôt adeptes de la realpolitik et que
quand à court terme leurs enjeux car
l'intérêt du pays sont en jeu ils sont
capables de prendre des mesures
drastiques sur un temps très très réduit
et qui dans la vie avec de tricher avec
les tchèques vous l'avez mentionné et
qui tienne compte avant tout de leurs
intérêts nationaux
au delà de au delà de ces projets de tes
projets européens donc il ne faut jamais
jamais oublier cela et à côté
effectivement il n'irait pas jusqu'à
parler de laïcité d'être encore une fois
nous notre volonté de travailler dans la
durée avec les voisins allemands pour la
gestion de cette crise parce que cette
interdépendance au niveau frontaliers
elle bénéficie à nos à nos deux
économies des départements et des länder
guana et qu'on a toujours travaillé en
bonne intelligence
les camps berlin vient se mêler de cette
affaire là et tape du poing sur la table
je souvent de manière très très dur une
réunion en tout cas se tiendra demain
entre angela merkel et les länder avec
peut-être voir des assouplissements
c'est ce qu'on vous souhaite en tout cas
en moselle merci avoue fabien philippot
d'avoir été avec lui beaucoup et face à
la pandémie mondiale
certains pays européens ont pris la
décision d'alléger les restrictions dans
l'espoir de relancer l'économie
les assouplissements qui contredisent la
tendance générale cyrielle ball et
l'autriche
à contre-courant face à la fin des mii
de copies de 19 ce lundi les autorités
du pays ont fait savoir qu'elles
prévoyaient la réouverture des terrasses
cafés et restaurants dans le courant du
mois de mars
un assouplissement des mesures à
condition de limiter les nouveaux cas de
contamination
nous voulons arriver à pâques sans que
le nombre de personnes infectées
n'augmente de façon explosive
mais si les chiffres connaissent une
croissance exponentielle
il faudra se passer de ces
assouplissements autres pays concernés
par la levée des restrictions la croatie
après presque quatre mois de fermeture
les restaurants et cafés ont rouvert
leurs portes ce lundi dans le centre
ville de zagreb
les terrasses ont été vite prise
d'assaut par les clients nous sommes
très heureux que les bars ouvre enfin
nous attendions tous ce moment on
espérait pouvoir ouvrir vers le premier
ou le 15 février
j'espère juste que les chiffres ne vont
pas encore augmenté et qu'ils devront à
nouveau fermé
si nous respectons les mesures
épidémiologique tout ira bien
nous pouvons profiter de nos amis boire
un café ensemble parler et profiter du
beau temps
j'espère que ça ira mieux une décision
gouvernementale en faveur de la reprise
économique alors même que la croatie est
confronté à l'émergence dé souche
britannique et sud africaines du virus
l'allemagne s'est également positionnée
afin de relancer l'économie du pays
lourdement affectés par la pandémie
le land du brandebourg est celui de
bavière ont ainsi autorisé la
réouverture des fleuristes et des
magasins spécialisés dans le jardinage
une décision approuvée par les clients
ravis de ce quasi retour à la normale
oui c'est déjà un peu un retour à la
normalité c'est sûr et peut-être que si
les magasins rouvrent progressivement
alors cela va certainement ramener un
peu de vie normale je pense que
signifient les mesures d'hygiène telles
qu'elles sont décrites cela
fonctionnerait aussi la chancelière
allemande angela merkel doit rencontrer
les premiers ministres des états fédérés
à berlin ce mercredi pour discuter des
prochains assouplissement pour tenter de
ralentir la pandémie les magasins jugés
non essentiels sont fermés en allemagne
depuis le mois de décembre dans ceux des
quatre variants britannique en
république tchèque mais aussi en
slovaquie est les deux pays d'europe
centrale sont les plus touchées l'union
européenne le taux d'incidence est
d'ailleurs le plus élevé de l'union la
république tchèque affiché hier lundi
1120 cas pour 100000 habitants prague et
bratislava rend tous les deux fait appel
aux vaccins russe ou pleurer pour tenter
d'en vis de l'épidémie qui a sauvé qui a
reçu hier son premier lot écouter le
premier ministre je pense qu'en
respectant les délais
d'approvisionnement promis la vessie
prouvera qu'elle est un partenaire
stable sur lequel nous pouvons compter
en ces temps difficiles j'ai étant donné
que la pandémie de coal india ne fait
pas attention aux questions
géopolitiques et que la protection des
vies humaines
prévost par dessus tout nous avons jugé
bon d'acheter un mac sans risque pour
que les slovaques qui le souhaitent
puissent se faire vacciner
en tunisie la campagne de vaccination
anti copie de 19 crise peut un peu les
relations entre le président et le
premier ministre en cause mille doses de
vaccins offerts par abou dhabi affirmant
ne pas en avoir été informé le chef du
gouvernement a ordonné l'ouverture d'une
enquête et ce en pleine crise politique
la correspondance à tunis de baisse m
shelly c'est un énième bras de fer au
sommet de l'état entre le président de
la république monsieur car il sera aidé
son premier ministre monsieur hichem
mais chichi sujet de cette nouvelle
confrontation l'introduction de mille
doses de vaccin sur le territoire le
tunisien offert par les émirats arabes
unis le président de la république les
aurait mis à la disposition de la santé
et militaires sous pression carthage a
confirmé l'arrivée de ces vaccins une
arrivée que le gouvernement ignore le
premier ministre a demandé l'ouverture
immédiate d'une enquête sur les
circonstances de l'arrivée de ces un
vaccin leurs conditions de stockage leur
gestion ainsi que leur distribution
un bras de fer entre les deux hommes
après la hulluch remaniement ministériel
qu'il y avait ici en tunisie il ya
quelques semaines où onze nouveaux
ministres ont été nommés par le premier
ministre sous pression du parti
islamiste ennahda des ministres qui
n'ont pas été validés par le président
de la république et qu'ils jugent
certains comme aux corrompus alors que
les voisins maghrébins tels que l'égypte
le maroc ou l'algérie ont déjà commencé
leur campagne de vaccination la tunisie
est toujours à la traîne
des contrats ont été négociés et signés
notamment avec le groupe pfizer
d'autres decaux contrats sont encore en
négociation avec le vaccin en russe se
foutent nick v et puis pékin a fait
savoir qu'il pourrait livrer plus de
cent mille doses à gratuitement à la
tunisie la tunisie qui est à la traîne
et qui peine à gérer cette crise du
coronavirus notamment en termes de
vaccination il faut compter 2 133 1277
contamination depuis le début de cette
pandémie pour un total de 8000 à mort
sur le territoire tunisien pays
limitrophe de l'arabie saoudite le yémen
où les états unis washington sanctionne
aujourd'hui deux militants clé des
rebelles houthi un pays pour lequel
seuls 1,7 milliard de dollars ont été
récoltés hier sur les 3,85 espéré lors
d'une conférence de donateurs
une enveloppe insuffisante selon les
nuques il a comparé jeu suite à une
peine de mort pour un pays toujours en
proie à la guerre et où sévit selon les
nations unies la pire crise humanitaire
au monde
sentiment partagé par une population qui
continue de souffrir de la faim il ya un
an
nous avons été très surpris et nous
considérons que c'est une insulte envers
les yéménites de ne récolter que 1,7
milliard de dollars de la part de tous
les pays
je pense que ce montant est insultes
envers des yéménites dérivés savent que
nous sommes assiégés et qui nous
subissons une dire un juste l'argent
donné par les donateurs sera versé au
gouvernement légitime mais nous sommes à
peu près sûr que les yéménites en
bénéficieront pas même pas 1%
tous les yéménites espèrent que la
guerre prendra fin le plus tôt possible
et que nous aurons plus besoin d'une
telle aide à des nomades
après bruxelles hier washington annonce
à son tour aujourd'hui une salve de
mesures contre moscou en toile de fond
la sphère alexeï navalni plus de
précision avec notre correspondant en
russie antoine claireaux les etats-unis
ont annoncé avoir adopté des sanctions
contre cette personne physique et 14
organisations suspecté d'avoir pris part
à l'élaboration d'armes biologiques ou
chimiques
il s'agit là de la première action
concrète de l'administration byden à
l'encontre de la russie
le renseignement américain estime avec
je cite un haut degré de confiance que
des agents du fsb ont utilisé un agent
innervant pour empoisonner alexeï
navalni ces sanctions
cherchez donc à punir la russie dans le
cadre de la sphère navalni mais aussi
pour l' ingérence présumée dans les
élections américaines ou encore avec
l'accusation d' attaque informatique
contre solar wind pour l'instant on ne
connaît pas encore l'identité des
personnes et des organisations visées au
contraire des sanctions européennes en
effet quelques minutes avant l'annoncé
américaine l'union européenne publiée
officiellement les noms des quatre hauts
responsables russes impliqués d'après
bruxelles dont l'empoisonnement supposé
d'alexey navalni ces quatre personnes
sont toutes des hauts fonctionnaires le
procureur général le chef du comité
d'investigation celui de la garde
nationale ainsi que le directeur des
services pénitentiaires
place maintenant à la réaction de moscou
en effet sergueï lavrov plus tôt dans la
journée a promis que ces sanctions
européennes comme américaines ne
resterait pas sans réponse et c'est la
fin de cette émission merci d'avoir
suivi prochain point complet sur
l'actualité ce sera dans quelques
minutes avec emilie gogh h
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde je suis
répond un appartement on est énervé
donnait le sentiment qu'il faut à chaque
fois se battre ils vivent parfois au
bord des routes nationales pas forcément
loin de paris mais toujours loin de ceux
qui les dirigent
moi je voudrais pas qu'on les fasse un
tour de tracteur avec bouclé la campagne
il faut savoir c'est qu'une vie
différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles ma forêt td quoi un peu plus
aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans va de suicide et
ça ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que les gaffes à ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom et dans l'hymne quel
rôle pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu et
big for books les gaffes à s'organiser
pour annuler quelqu'un sur internet ce
que quelqu'un s'était donald trump quand
il s'agit d'un bannissement si général
pour moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et
aux réseaux sociaux à dole à des
entreprises privées de prendre cette
décision mais ça doit être à la justice
de prendre cette décision
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
et y'a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
saper une volonté collectés vous savez
comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y a pas
d'alternative on sort du public
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des soul unis vers une forme risquant
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose d'inouï
et gilet jaune c'était des valeurs de
droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas là l'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
ce qu'on attend un peu de vous c'est les
idées pour en sortir est votre jugement
notamment de la façon dont cette crise
est gérée ce qui a été montré au cours
de la gestion de cette crise c'est le
déficit d'anticipation pour moi la
politique c'est d'abord d'être efficace
dès qu'un manque de cohérence
il ya il ya un manque de fiabilité il ya
un manque de confiance faut vite
retrouver la confiance vous considérer
aujourd'hui que que la france a été plus
mauvaise que beaucoup de nos pays
étrangers nous sommes le pays qui a
inventé les vaccins avec pasteur dont la
réactivité française n'a pas été à la
hauteur de notre réputation tout le
monde a vu que dès le mois de juillet
les chinois vacciner pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a attendu si longtemps
la question est de savoir comment est-ce
qu'on va retrouver un équilibre en
faisant en sorte que les épreuves que
nous subissons actuellement deviennent
des forces et non pas des handicaps
durable
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
accélérer et faciliter la campagne de
vaccination c'est ce que vise la haute
autorité de santé plusieurs
recommandations ont été faites
l'élargissement du personnel de santé
pour en vacciner l'autorisation du
vaccin astrazeneca aux personnes de plus
de 65 ans présentant des commandes
des positions qui arrive à la veille
d'un conseil de défense sanitaire ou de
nouvelles restrictions sanitaires vont
être décidées
[Musique]
il ne semble pas prêt à changer d'avis
le président arménien a une fois de plus
refusé de limoger le chef de l'armée une
demande du premier ministre
nikol pashinian qui reste sous le feu
des critiques depuis la signature d'un
accord de cessez-le-feu avec
l'azerbaïdjan dans le conflit de haut
karabagh la proposition du chef de
gouvernement d'organiser des élections
anticipées restent insuffisantes pour
apaiser la colère des manifestants
[Musique]
et puis le prince héritier d'arabie
saoudite visé par une plainte pour
crimes contre l'humanité en allemagne
départ l'ol gevo portèrent sans
frontières elle porte sur la persécution
généralisée et systématique des
journalistes
arabie saoudite angie dénonce également
la responsabilité
mohammed bin salman dans l'assassinât du
journaliste saoudien jamal khashoggi
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
si vous nous rejoignez sur rt france il
est 22h conseil de défense sanitaire
demain l'exécutif a prévenu s'il n'y a
pas d'amélioration dans les vingt
départements placés sous surveillance un
resserrement des restrictions sanitaires
sera à prononcer de son côté lors d'une
conférence de presse la haute autorité
de santé a dévoilé des propositions pour
accélérer la campagne de vaccination les
précisions depuis l'elysée de mona a
model le gouvernement veut passer à la
vitesse supérieure alors que seuls les
médecins pouvaient vacciner la haute
autorité de la santé recommande que les
pharmaciens les infirmiers ou encore
elle est sage femme puisse administrer
tous les vaccins confondus à savoir l
astra zeneca le moderna ou encore le
finder premièrement l'objectif est
d'étendre la charge de travail pour
aller au plus vite et vacciner un
maximum de français et puis diversifier
le profil des vaccinateurs multiplier
les lieux de vaccination pour finalement
la simplifier et puis selon elle la
haute autorité et de la santé les
pharmaciens pourraient même prescrire
des vaccins anti qu'ovide d'alors
concernant ces vaccins s'il astrazeneca
était un peu le mal aimé à des vaccins
anti qu'ovide pour les 65 75 ans c'est
parce que les autorités sanitaires
manqué de données efficaces concernant
un public âgé mais une étude écossaise
ses biens a fait pencher la balance en
sa faveur et est d'après cette étude
écossaise et bien
le vaccin astrazeneca aurait une
efficacité comparable aux vaccins files
heures sur un nombre élevé de patients
âgés
le vaccin britannique est presque en
train d'inverser la tendance c'est ce
qui a confirmé olivier ferrand le
ministre de la santé écoutez le la haute
autorité de santé considère désormais
depuis aujourd'hui que tous les vaccins
dont nous disposons en france le
astrazeneca le finder et le modern art
où une efficacité qualifié de
remarquable elle désormais le vaccin
astrazeneca va être étendu aux 65 75 ans
atteint de comorbidité soit 2.5 millions
de français écouter à nouveau le
ministre de la santé
désormais les personnes âgées de 50 ans
et plus incluant les 65 75 ans qui
souffre de ce qu'on appelle des
comorbidités des fragilités pourront se
faire vacciner avec astrazeneca chez
leur médecin traitant dans l'hôpital qui
les suit ou dans quelques jours en
pharmacie je peux acté que désormais
toutes les personnes de 50 ans et plus
qui ont des fragilités peuvent se faire
vacciner avec le vaccin astrazeneca sans
limite d'âge
à la veille du conseil sanitaire de
défense s'il n'y a pas d'amélioration
dans les vingt départements placés sous
surveillance et l'exécutif va devoir
envisager un nouveau tour de vis à la
veille et de ce conseil le gouvernement
travaille sur plusieurs mesures
concrètes et ciblées par exemple un
confinement le week-end mais pour
l'instant rien n'est sûr plusieurs
scénarios sont en discussion et les
décisions seront donc prises en fonction
et des concertations et surtout en
fonction de l'évolution de l'épidémie en
première ligne depuis un an face à la
pandémie le personnel de santé qui doit
parfois faire face à la violence plus de
400 actes violents liés aux kovy 19 ont
été recensés dans le monde l'année
dernière c'est ce qui ressort d'un
rapport de la coalition pour la
sauvegarde de la santé lors des conflits
des situations qui se manifeste par des
injures ou des coûts pour christina
weale membre de
ong de défense des soignants il faut
faire de la prévention et aider le
personnel de santé à gérer ces
situations il faut vraiment qu'on
améliorer la prévention pour que ça sera
pas les médecins les infirmières qui
s'il a la frustration des populations a
omis dans les périodes économie est une
question de communication des
gouvernements mais c'est aussi une
question comment on peut aider le
personnel de santé de vraiment
communication en situation où il y aller
les familles de kiki vous avoir des
informations donc c'est vraiment la
communication les niveaux donc aidé tout
au du gouvernement mais aussi dans les
situations direct dans les hôpitaux
hôpitaux 6,25 millions de français ne
savent toujours pas s'ils seront bientôt
à confiner les week-ends dès lundi
prochain les allemands pourrait
bénéficier d'un allègement des
restrictions sanitaires c'est ce que va
proposer dès demain la chancelière
angela merkel
d'autres pays européens comme la croatie
ont déjà commencé à alléger leurs
restrictions sanitaires
cyrielle boe
l'autriche à contre-courant face à la
pandémie de kobe de 19
ce lundi les autorités du pays ont fait
savoir qu'elles prévoyaient la
réouverture des terrasses cafés et
restaurants dans le courant du mois de
mars
un assouplissement des mesures à
condition de limiter les nouveaux cas de
contamination
nous voulons arriver à pâques sans que
le nombre de personnes infectées
n'augmente de façon explosive
mais si les chiffres connaissent une
croissance exponentielle
il faudra se passer de ces
assouplissements autres pays concernés
par la levée des restrictions la croatie
après presque quatre mois de fermeture
les restaurants et cafés ont rouvert
leurs portes ce lundi dans le centre
ville de zagreb
les terrasses ou été vite prise d'assaut
par les clients nous sommes très heureux
que les bars ouvre enfin nous attendions
tous ce moment on espérait pouvoir
ouvrir vers le premier ou le 15 février
j'espère juste que les chiffres ne vont
pas encore augmenté et qu'ils devront à
nouveau fermé
si nous respectons les mesures
épidémiologique tout ira bien
nous pouvons profiter de nos amis boire
un café ensemble parler et profiter du
beau temps
j'espère que ça ira mieux une décision
gouvernementale en faveur de la reprise
économique alors même que la croatie est
confronté à l'émergence dé souche
britannique et sud africaines du virus
l'allemagne s'est également positionnée
afin de relancer l'économie du pays
lourdement affectés par la pandémie
le land du brandebourg est celui de
bavière ont ainsi autorisé la
réouverture des fleuristes et des
magasins spécialisés dans le jardinage
une décision approuvée par les clients
ravis de ce quasi retour à la normale
oui c'est déjà un peu un retour à la
normalité c'est sûr et peut-être que si
les magasins rouvrent progressivement
alors cela va certainement ramener un
peu de vie normale je pense que s'ils
n'ont fui les mesures d'hygiène telles
qu'elles sont décrites cela
fonctionnerait aussi la chancelière
allemande angela merkel doit rencontrer
les premiers ministres des états fédérés
à berlin ce mercredi pour discuter des
prochains assouplissement pour tenter de
ralentir la pandémie les magasins jugés
non essentiels sont fermés en allemagne
depuis le mois de décembre la république
tchèque et la slovaquie face à une
hausse des cas de variants britannique
les deux pays d'europe centrale sont les
plus touchés de l'union européenne le
taux d'incidence est d'ailleurs le plus
élevé
l'union européenne la république tchèque
affiché hier 1120 cas pour 100000
habitants prague et bratislava ont tous
deux fait appel aux vaccins bruce spots
mode ev pour tenter d'endiguer
l'épidémie
la slovaquie a reçu hier son premier lot
son premier ministre igor matovic s'est
exprimé à ce sujet je pense qu'en
respectant les délais les
approvisionnements promis la russie
prouvera qu'elle est un partenaire
stable sur lequel nous pouvons compter
en ces temps difficiles
étant donné que la pandémie de call it
is 9 ne fait pas attention questions
géopolitiques et que la protection des
vies humaines
prévost par dessus tout nous avons jugé
bon d'acheter un accent russe pour que
les slovaques qui le souhaitent puissent
se faire vacciner
autre titre de cette édition les
manifestations qui se poursuivent en
arménie en pays toujours plongé dans une
crise politique majeure
le président refuse encore le limogeage
du chef d'état-major un officiel de haut
rang poussé vers la sortie par le
premier ministre nikol pashinian de plus
en plus en difficulté depuis la
signature cet automne d'un accord de
cessez-le-feu avec l'azerbaïdjan dans le
conflit et du haut karabagh saha
proposition d'élections anticipées le
calme toujours pas la vue plus de
précision depuis erevan avec notre
envoyé spécial david khalifa
une mobilisation moins importante que
lors des précédents jours mais une
poignée de manifestants toujours là pour
réclamer le départ de nikol pashinian et
comme vous pouvez le voir derrière moi
des rubans orange ont été accrochées aux
grilles du parlement un pied de nez fait
à nikol pashinian puisque elle
représente le souvenir des villageois
qui sont désormais sous l'égide de
l'azerbaïdjan le premier ministre
arménien considéré comme responsable de
la défaite militaire dans leur haut
karabagh et cette mobilisation elle
s'est faite en présence d'une des
figures de l'opposition vazguen
manoukian anciens premiers ministres de
l'arménie et qui a demandé à tous les
partisans antipas chilienne de
poursuivre le combat jusqu'à son
éviction
il a également précisé qu'un rendez vous
était pris avec le président arménien
demain matin afin qu'ils fassent tout ce
qui est en son pouvoir pour garder en
poste le chef d'état major de l'armée
vous le savez unique aux alpes à xi'an a
réclamé sa révocation à plusieurs
reprises une révocation refusée par le
président arménien mais a selon la
constitution il est obligé d'accepter
cette motion d'où ce rendez-vous a pris
par l'opposition demain matin avec le
président arménien je vous propose
d'écouter base gagne manucure à notre
micro
ni escale technique dans mon aux autres
il y a quelqu'un joue le président a
renvoyé la proposition d'un nikol
pashinian l'argument est temps qu'elle
n'était pas conforme à la constitution
la constitution n'a pas changé pendant
ces quelques jours donc ce qui était
anticonstitutionnelle il y a quelques
jours l'est encore aujourd'hui
logique il devrait donc renvoyé ce
papier à la cour constitutionnelle
c'est la décision la plus naturelle mais
il a du temps jusqu'à 18 heures demain
nous espérons que nous serons le
convaincre ou plutôt en lui indiquant
qu'en toute logique cette proposition de
nikol pashinian devrait être renvoyée à
la cour constitutionnelle
ensuite la cour constitutionnelle les
qui durera pendant dix jours une
nouvelle mobilisation est prévue demain
à 16h heure locale devant le parlement
arménien afin de maintenir cette
pression sur le premier ministre
arménien elle appelle de vazgen manucho
et qui demande à tous les partisans de
poursuivre le combat jusqu'à son
éviction à savoir que la sécurité a été
renforcée
tout autour des bâtiments administratifs
pour éviter toute incursion à des
partisans antifascisme et comme il ya pu
y avoir lors des précédents jours
mohammed bin salman visé par une plainte
pour crimes contre l'humanité en
allemagne je vous le disais en titre une
plainte déposée par les ong reporters
sans frontières qui porte sur la
persécution généralisée et systématique
des journalistes en arabie saoudite
les ong dénoncent également la
responsabilité du prince héritier
d'arabie saoudite dans l'assassinât du
journaliste saoudien jamal rachid j
françois xavier lambert la justice
allemande va se pencher sur une affaire
qui embarrasse le pouvoir saoudien dans
une plante de plusieurs centaines de
pages adressée au procureur général de
la cour constitutionnelle fédérale de
karlsruhe et reporters sans frontières
accuse plusieurs hauts responsables
saoudiens de persécuter systématiquement
les journalistes cette juridiction jouit
notamment d'une compétence universelle
qui lui permet de juger certains crimes
commis à l'étranger et elle va donc
devoir se prononcer sur une plainte qui
met directement en cause le
tout-puissant prince héritier mohammed
bin salman
il est accusé entre autres de torture de
violence ou de disparitions forcées
exercée contre 34 journalistes
nous demandons une analyse de la
situation en vue d'ouvrir de manière
officielle une enquête du ministère
public qui serait une première mondiale
avant d'émettre ensuite des mandats
d'arrêt cette nouvelle accusation contre
eux mbs s'ajoutent aux conclusions de
l'enquêté des services secrets
américains sur son rôle présumé dans
l'assassinât du journaliste jamal
arrache audi pour washington c'est bien
lui qui a donné le feu vert à
l'opération
le prince héritier d'arabie saoudite
mohammad bin salman a validé une
opération à istanbul en turquie pour
capturer ou tuer le journaliste saoudien
jamal rachid
après avoir nié son assassinat ryad a
reconnu que plusieurs agents saoudiens
avaient tué jamal arrache audi en
octobre 2018 dans le consulat d'arabie
saoudite à istanbul
le journaliste critique envers le
pouvoir saoudien s'était exilé aux états
unis avant de collaborer avec le
washington post
selon le renseignement américain une
vingtaine de personnes dont l'ancien
directeur adjoint des renseignements
généraux saoudiens sont impliqués dans
cette opération
les etats unis ont annoncé des sanctions
financières contre plusieurs
responsables saoudiens 76 personnes sont
désormais interdites de séjour aux états
unis
le prince héritier lui n'est pas
concerné par ces mesures restrictives le
royaume wahhabite continue de rejeter
les accusations contre eux mb s
nous n'avons pas besoin d'être soulagé
parce que nous n'avons jamais pensé que
c'était une possibilité sérieuse
le prince héritier n'est pas impliqué
dans ce processus et a été innocenté de
tout acte répréhensible
il a endossé la responsabilité morale en
tant que dirigeant courageux et cela
signifie veiller à ce que la situation
soit rectifiée et les responsables de ce
crime odieux traduits en justice la
justice saoudienne a condamné huit des
accusés à des peines de prison mais
aucun responsable de premier plan
c'est dans ce contexte que le président
américain s'est entretenu la semaine
dernière au téléphone avec le roi salman
le souverain qui a insisté pour
maintenir un partenariat solide avec les
états unis selon le classement mondial
de la liberté de la